Monday January 22nd meeting of science
technology and energy we have a
presentation first thing this morning
but before we get to that I'd like to
ask everybody to rise and join
representative Vice chair Thomas in the
Allegiance i al to flag the United
States of America to The Republic which
stands one nation under God indivisible
all all right thank you everybody we
have a full day of activity here today
we're going to have a presentation in
just a few
minutes between now and 10:00 and at
10:00 we're going to
resume the public hearing on House Bill
1697 FN suspending New Hampshire's
participation in emissions reduction
credit programs for a period of two
years after that hearing concludes we
will take a lunch break come back at 1
p.m. for the continuation of a public
hearing on House Bill 1700
dfn prohibiting the intentional release
of polluting emissions including cloud
seating weather
modification excessive electromagnetic
radio frequency and microwave radiation
and making penalties for violation of
such
prohibition that public hearing will be
followed by our
final public hearing of the
day that's on hb1 1472 FN relative to
rebates of Energy Efficiency funds for
electric
vehicles so that is the agenda for today
actually that is the agenda for this
week because tomorrow being primary
election day we will not be in
session we do have two full days
scheduled for next week though on Monday
January 29th and Tuesday
January
30th so with that I'd like to begin our
presentation this
morning we're fortunate to have Charlie
LEC of the forest uh Owners Association
or he'll explain exactly what he's a
member of uh to give us a presentation
on Forest carbon credits so Charlie take
it away thank you Mr chair members of
the committee you all should have a
paper copy of the point in front of you
and there's a few extra copies over here
for members of the public if uh if they
would like that so I wear several
different hats coming here before you um
really the Hat I'm here with is as the
contract executive director for
something called the Northeast State
Foresters Association so New Hampshire
we have a state Forester that's Patrick
Hackley is in the room you know who he
is and his counterparts in the Northeast
have a nonprofit that we basically do a
bunch of research work for and I've been
working for them for about 25 years and
under that we have this program that's
been going on for a couple years called
securing Northeast Forest carbon program
it's that logo up on the screen uh and
that program is designed essentially to
educate any and all those interested in
Forest carbon Forest carbon science and
Forest carbon markets that's what we've
been up to for a couple years in a seven
state region of New York and New England
so this comes from that greater
geography uh I'm bringing it to you my
day job is actually uh as uh the
president of a small nonprofit small
Consulting organization based in New
Hampshire and we have offices in Maine
as well Innovative natural resource
Solutions so I point you to our website
for securing Northeast Forest carbon
here it is Northeast Forest caron.org
everything I'm going to be talking about
and more is at that website so consider
consider it a resource for you and for
everybody else about the topic uh that
we're going to cover today we've tried
to be thorough there's no other single
place where you can get all this
information uh to educate you and others
on Forest carbon and Forest carbon
markets so I'm going to start a little
bit by talking about Connecticut Lakes
because that's where all this comes from
the bill that you have before you I I
wear another hat in that I am a member
of the citizens committee the
Connecticut Lake Headwater citizens
committee which is a statutory committee
that came out of the project starting in
2003 and the map you have before you is
the Connecticut Lakes property uh I'm
not sure I think you can see the colors
up there you can see it certainly in
your paper copies so um this is the the
part of geography of New Hampshire that
this proper property sits North is
Canada to the east is Maine and to the
West is really Canada and Vermont down
in the bottom leftand corner to give you
some sense it's the very Northern tip of
New Hampshire and just some brief
history and then I'll jump into Forest
carbon in 2001 um a nonprofit National
nonprofit called the trust for public
land uh got an option on what was then
owned by International Paper Company at
the time it was
171,00 acres and it took two years to
put together a conservation project that
resulted in what we have today so coming
out out of that uh
146,00 Acres uh went to a private
landowner the Connecticut Lakes realy
trust which was lime Timber at the time
now this is a rural sustainable lands
which you heard about at the first
hearing on this uh and the intent was
that that property subject to a
conservation easement would be managed
as a working force producing Timber
essentially in
perpetuity also as part of that deal and
very unique arrangement in that the
state of New Hampshire through uh
Department of Natural cultural resources
essentially acquired the main Gravel
Road system in that
46,4 Acres it's you won't see this
anywhere else it's about 269 miles of
the 424 gravel road miles on that
property and and also as part of that
the state of New Hampshire uh retained
all the recreation rights so all the
recreation that goes on in this property
um again privately owned by now Aurora
sustainable lands LLC is owned by the
state of New Hampshire and managed uh
along with the RADS so also at that time
25,000 acres and if you've got your map
on the piece of paper you can see a
different color greenish color uh that
25,000 Acres was deeded uh in fee to the
state of New Hampshire and managed now
by the fish and game department and it
was the the most highly sensitive lands
at the time that were set aside um just
a side note fishing game actually does
harvest some Timber on that land as well
it's wildli directed but there are
ongoing harvests that go on on that that
property as well again owned by the
state of New Hampshire another 100 acres
which you can't really see anywhere uh
but if you've been to the North country
and you know this property there uh
there is a campground managed by the
state of New Hampshire Deer Mountain
Campground 100 acres was deeded to the
state around that Campground for future
expansion
and that's really what happened so who
paid for all this you all did in part at
the time uh the capital budget had $10
million in it along with $2 million from
elip and then the federal government put
in a like amount from the forest Legacy
program and lime Timber bought the
underlying fee to balance out the full
uh amount of dollars raised which was
$45 million in 2003 to make this
property happen so that's a little
background on the property thought it
would be helpful to to get some history
so lime Timber owned
146,00 Acres again the yellow on the map
uh until 2009 then the forest Land Group
purchased it and owned it until 2
2022 and that's when uh Aurora
sustainable lands at the time blue
Source purchased uh the property uh and
continues to own it so a little history
there thought would be helpful to start
out I'm going to jump into Forest
carbon and before we get into talking
about the markets there's a there's a
little bit of the science that just as
reminders it's helpful to understand so
as we think about what's being bought
and sold here so remember from your high
school biology uh thinking about what
trees and plants do in photosynthesis
right they take in carbon dioxide plus
water plus sunlight with chlorophyll and
they produce food sugars essentially and
they also uh emit oxygen for us to
breathe so uh through that process in in
the process of photosynthesis the tree
grows and half of the wood part of the
tree or really the biomass of the tree
uh is uh in terms of the dry weight is
carbon okay and so that's what
everybody's after is the fact that these
plants take CO2 out of the air that's a
greenhouse gas
uh and and the most ubiquitous one and
uh and in fact stores it long term in
the trees and that's what's getting paid
for in the markets um understand however
that you know in climates like ours
where we have winter these trees
actually kind of shut down in the
wintertime they're not sequestering
carbon I'll talk about the terms after
but they're not doing that during the
wintertime but they more than make up
for it during the summertime when trees
are growing uh and so that overtime time
if you see the slide I have up here uh
that graph on the bottom right don't
need to know the details but that upward
trajectory is showing the increasing
carbon over time the x-axis is is time
so that's what happens so the trees
don't die in the winter they shut down
and during that time they're still alive
and they actually give off more carbon
dioxide during the during that that
close period Then they take in because
they're not doing photosynthesis so
that's why you see that Jagged red line
on the graph down there so a little
background science on there that I
thought it'd be helpful so a few key
terms in this field that we need to talk
about carbon storage in terms of forest
is the carbon stored in the trees
primarily in the wood but don't forget
we've got branches and leaves and all
those smaller parts of the tree but
that's the storage that is the tree
taking in the CO2 in the past it it
shows up as the as the plant looks like
today carbon sequestration is actually
the tree's active activity of taking in
that carbon dioxide and once it does
that and creates the sugars and the wood
then that turns into carbon storage but
it's the sequestration that is equally
as important I think it's more important
simply because it's taking out CO2 from
the atmosphere today and that's what
we're all concerned about right with the
greenhouse gas emissions that are
happening today the carbon storage is
great we don't want to release that but
the sequestration is the active part of
it that we're most concerned about
carbon emissions as we know can come
from any kind of entity that uh Burns
any kind of fuel we talk about fossil
fuels but just remember to be honest
when you burn wood in your wood stove I
have two in my house we're releasing uh
carbon dioxide greenhouse gases the
atmosphere as part of that so that's
that stored carbon in the tree that is
now getting released however if we take
that same wood and we make it into a
table like these tables that gets stored
for a long long time continues to be
stored so that's something to take into
account I'll touch on that again so the
key thing is this thing called carbon
flux in the Box on the right uh on on
this slide and that is what is the
difference between the sequestration in
in a time period and usually we talk
about a year and the emissions because
trees again give off uh carbon dioxide
as part of respiration because they are
alive and that difference is the carbon
flux a negative carbon flux means that
the tree is taking in more carbon
dioxide then it's giving off in a time
period usually we talk about a year so a
negative carbon flux is a good thing
because that's that's really what trees
uh trees are doing and a little bit in
the way of Statistics here because this
project is looking at this this
geography that you see before you New
York and New England is that the region
as a whole and and on this map uh if you
can see colors the darker the green the
higher density of the carbon and Timber
essentially that's what this is showing
you'll notice in northern Maine uh it's
a lighter color because the density of
trees there because that the state has
harvested more of its wood over time is
less so than it is in most of New
Hampshire but anyways this this uh shows
a little bit of data in that the region
as a whole is storing 54 years worth of
the current annual greenhouse gas
emission from all sour our es that means
the transportation system factories
power plants Etc so our trees are
substantial in the Northeast region and
they store a tremendous amount of carbon
you can see the breakdown of the seven
states in the two graphs and you'll see
that in total Forest carbon storage New
Hampshire is in the lower area that's
simply because it's a smaller State
compared to the two big states in the
region Maine and New York but the bottom
one is more important that is the carbon
storage per acre and you'll see New
Hampshire is right right in the thick of
it uh with the other states with
Massachusetts having the most carbon
stored in its Forest per acre of all
these seven
states and Mr chairman we talked earlier
but if anybody has any questions during
the presentation feel free to just
interrupt me and we can cover something
then Forest carbon pools this is
important because when we get to markets
we need to know what these markets are
actually paying for and so um you'll
notice the pie charts on the left are
looking at storage and sequestration we
now know what those mean but the active
part of the various carbon pools that we
have meaning the actual live trees above
and below ground the litter the forest
uh the top of the soil the soil itself
and dead wood material which in in any
Forest it's all over the place those are
the carbon pools but the active part
where stuff happens where the
sequestration happens is in the above
ground and below ground uh tree uh part
of it you'll see in the bottom uh pie
chart that the above ground live biomass
and the below ground live biomass where
the bulk of anything happens in terms of
sequestering taking carbon dioxide out
of the air but just know that the the
forest itself stores it in a bunch of
different places the other take home
from this slide very briefly is that uh
when we look at Forest the soil itself
actually uh has about half of all the
carbon that's stored in a forest is
actually in the soil carbon markets do
not pay for that carbon markets are
really paying for the above and below
ground biomass uh in in the forest so
that's just something something to keep
in mind two two key Concepts on this in
the next graft and that is that in terms
of storage this first one this is this
graph is looking at a forest over 125
years Forest can live and grow a lot
longer than that um but that's what this
graph is showing and that it is simply
showing that over time a forest that is
older has more carbon stored in it kind
of a no-brainer an older Forest probably
has bigger trees than a younger forest
and so uh it stores more carbon per area
Acre state county whatever we want to
talk about but the second concept that's
really important is the concept of
sequestration because that first one is
storage this one is sequestration on the
second slide uh you'll notice that
younger Forest actually sequester more
carbon per area than older forest and
that's simply because they're growing
vigorously they have many more stems and
ultimately they have many more leaes uh
Lea leaves in the forest or needles and
that leaf surface or needle surface is
greater than in an older Forest where
you have some gaps right and so two
different concepts important to
understand and remember I mentioned that
a negative carbon flux is a good thing
that's what this gra graph is showing
when you see the graph dip down for soil
Deadwood litter and live trees that's
because that's the part of the life
lifespan where the the forest is
sequestering the most carbon over the
life of the forest so it really uh is
showing it in a negative simply because
it's taking in more than it's giving off
and the zero is is in the top part of
that uh that y
AIS and then lastly I just mentioned
before it's important to understand when
we Harvest Timber we're not necessarily
releasing all that carbon to the
atmosphere uh when we Harvest and that
wood goes into Long Live products uh
particularly solid wood products like a
lot of what these desks are made of in
this room uh that can that can be stored
for a long time in buildings we all know
in New England we've got buildings that
were built in the late 1600s early 1700s
they're still standing they are timber
frame so that wood has been stored for
hundreds of years so it's very possible
in solid wood for that to happen so as
we think about the other products that
are that are harvested um including
pulpwood which make goes into making
paper that's a short live product so it
lasts uh longer than if we burn it uh in
a wood stove but it doesn't last very
long it might last for 3 to seven years
whereas Long Live products like like the
the structure uh of all the wood in this
room can last for hundreds of years so
just something to keep in mind that we
don't necessarily release it all when we
cut trees we certainly release some of
it so we'll jump into the markets I
don't know if any questions about any of
that science or background but I thought
I'd start with that just to make sure
yes sir thank you I just want to make
sure um in terms of my understanding
about storage versus sequestration I
think of storage as the amount and
sequestration as the rate of change in
that amount that's correct good thank
you yeah thank you yes
sir
uh I I think there is such a thing as
soil decomposition as well which is
another flux right it's another carbon
di it doesn't the atmosphere so in the
soil uh there's a lot of carbon and it
doesn't necessarily stay static it does
change but it's actually relatively
stable compared to to compared to what's
going on in the live tree uh components
of the forest but it certainly does
change in fact it adds carbon as trees
drop leaves and branches and so forth
eventually that that makes it it's way
into the at least some of it makes it
makes its way into the soil and a lot of
that material as it rots actually
releases uh the the the CO2 and
sometimes methane into the atmosphere
both greenhouse
gases okay yes
sir since um since the flux rate is the
is the highest when a forest is younger
does doesn't that
um doesn't that leave lead to the
conclusion that it makes sense to be
actively harvesting
forests so because you're you're you're
you're taking the you're taking the wood
and you're hopefully putting it in
permanent places like homes and
Furniture right and then you're
replacing it with young plants that are
pulling a lot of carbon out of the
atmosphere it's a good observation it's
probably a little more complicated than
that uh in that what we don't want to do
is we don't want to take our older
forest and release all that carbon so
but even in a very high quality Forest
where you see a bunch of trees that that
that are this big and and they're
harvested out of that maybe 30% of that
volume will actually go into Long Live
products so it's not like you get 90%
because it's a high quality forest and
then in a lower quality Forest where you
got a bunch of deformed trees and we do
Forest improvements in that by removing
the dead and dying uh disease trees
most of that doesn't go into long life
so some of that can be but we really
don't want to be necessarily converting
older Forest to younger forest for that
purpose but when we have younger Forest
we certainly can increase the rate uh of
sequestration going on in those by doing
light thinnings of the disease and dying
trees so that the remaining trees are
healthy fast growing and we can get more
out of the forest that way so it's more
of an observation and you know when I
talk about young forests I'm talking
about forests that have average
diameters of trees like starting at this
to about like this no big big ones
generally so really small so 25 to 70
years is a forest that has trees in that
size
range
yes thank you um this is just a
clarification as well so then when when
we talk about sustainable forestry is is
the
sustainability in terms of the
the age and health of the forest or is
it sustainability in terms of the carbon
the net carbon uh footprint excellent
question um unfortunately there's no
Universal definition of sustainable
forestry so there are many different
takes on that so the most basic metric
out there that I use when I think about
sustainable forestry is how much is the
forest growing in a time period annually
compared to how much we're harvesting
right so New Hampshire we're blessed as
in all the states in this seven state
region in that annually we grow quite a
bit more forest volume meaning carbon
than we Harvest and that that gets lost
through land conversion to non-forest
use so we have about a 2:1 ratio in New
Hampshire right so for every year we're
growing twice the amount that we're
removing and that's a positive thing so
that's the most basic sustainability
metric that we want to start with there
are many more detailed definitions of
sustainability that are out there
because we have international uh
certification programs that actually
certify sustainability under a certain
definition on lands we have lands in New
Hampshire that are certified both to the
forest Stewardship Council and the
sustainable forestry initiative along
with Tree Farm which you probably are
aware of for smaller land owners those
are sustainability programs they measure
it they have standards and you meet
those so many different definitions but
that basic one of of Timber or carbon
sustainability is kind of where we
should start in my mind yes sir yeah
thank you for taking my question um
overall I'm just interested in the how
much uh carbon dioxide is stored in New
Hampshire Forest as compared to how much
is emitted worldwide what percentage
would that be worldwide I I don't know
that I could find out for you but I
don't know that yeah I imagine small
yeah I do know that for New Hampshire we
we uh sequester uh an amount that is
about equal to almost 30% of the total
emissions from all sources in New
Hampshire annually state of Maine
actually um you know these two states
have the highest percentage of Forest
Area you've probably heard it in the
country state of main Forest actually
sequester an amount equal to about 70%
of the greenhouse gases that are
emission that are emitted in Maine
annually so these two states you know
the Forest play a pretty significant
role in offsetting uh the emissions that
are occurring yes
sir yes thank you for taking my question
does the rate of
sequestration change with the
atmospheric concentration of
CO2 in other words if CO2 levels are
increasing do the trees take in more
well the the science is pretty clear
that as we get higher CO2 levels the
trees have access to more CO2 which is
their one of their key inputs so they
have documented that some uh additional
growth is occurring because of that and
also because average temperatures are
increasing over time so in a place like
New Hampshire I've been a Forester for
going on 45 years when I first started
we had probably two weeks less uh or
more of winter than we have today maybe
more right and that's additional grow
growing Seasons so the combination of
increased CO2 levels and longer growing
Seasons definitely is affecting our
forest a lot of other negative things
come along with that including evasive
species and a bunch of other stuff the
fact is yes our forests are growing a
bit more than they did as result I know
this committee has insatiable curiosity
about the subjects that we that come
before us but we do have some time
limits here we have a half hour left and
quite a bit of quite a few slides in the
presentation so I'd urge you to back off
on your questions just a little bit
thank you okay I'm I'm going to jump
into Force carbon offsets and obviously
if we have extra time at the end we can
come back to those other topics but you
probably know generally that when we're
talking about Force carbon offsets that
is a subset of the term carbon offsets
so uh in terms of what's being bought
and sold there are offsets being bought
and sold that don't come from forest but
I will say that the vast majority of the
carbon offsets being bought and sold
here and elsewhere in the world are from
forest because they are the biggest
natural source of sequestration that
goes on and so the concept is simple uh
on the left side of of this image shows
a factory or a power plant emitting um
carbon dioxide and if uh they've either
decided on their own to reduce those
emissions or uh state or federal law or
some other law in some other country
decides that they should be reducing
emissions uh they might have as an
option that they can reduce some
emissions at the stack but they can also
purchase offsets uh from a third party
to account for some of those emissions
and that's really what forc carbon
offsets are it's entities that are have
uh net emissions uh and in other words a
positive carbon flux over a time period
and they're purchasing offsets to offset
those emissions and in the forestry side
of things which is what what our focus
is today there are three kinds of um
projects aforestation or reforestation
where you have no forest and you plant
trees remember in New Hampshire in the
Northeast we don't we don't really plant
trees to any great degree because we
don't have to we have a climate and
ample uh rainfall so that uh we get
Forest Back naturally as you probably
know if you don't mow your lawn in your
backyard in 5 years you will have a
forest growing growing there I mean it's
just reality in this part of the world
but um if you uh aforestation projects
under Forest carbon offsets are planting
trees we know you're not going to see
that in New Hampshire avoided conversion
is another category uh but it's not done
very often the concept is there is this
property is imminently uh in track to be
developed to be changed from a forest to
a nonforest use whether that's
agriculture or developed use and you
stop that with the project we just don't
have many of those because they're very
complicated so where all the action is
in Forest carbon offsets is that third
management when we when we read about
the regional land trusts acquiring
tracts and saving a farm from potential
development as a subdivision isn't that
category 2 it is yeah it's a it's a good
uh observation because that's really the
work that our land trust I know the for
society's in here and there probably
others uh who do that dayto day um they
are doing that with sources of money and
donations of easements and they just
haven't tried to crack this knot and I'm
actually talking with a few land trusts
who kind of want to crack that nut of
number two and it just hasn't been done
just because it's complicated because
you know you need to proves somehow that
that land was going to be developed not
you think it's going to be developed it
was it is going to be developed if we
don't do this and that's the hard part
of of verifying it right and it which is
not unlike for improved Forest
management which we'll talk about so
improved Forest management is is two
things it is changes in the management
on Forest land uh where sequestration
would be different over time than if you
didn't sign a contract uh for the sale
of carbon offsets and that can be in two
forms one is actually Reserve where you
you set the land aside you don't Harvest
any timber at all when you had planned
on it during the contract period and
then secondly especially in the larger
ownerships like Connecticut Lakes what
we're talking about you can sell carbon
uh change your practices and also sell
Timber during the time period and I'll
get into that a little bit uh later so
improved Forest management is where the
action is for Forest carbon offsets here
and and elsewhere in North America so
some key terminology here for the forest
carbon Market markets in this nested set
of Concepts and so the carbon project
itself that gray Circle down at at the
bottom is a piece of forest on planet
Earth that we can identify you have to
prove you own it like any real estate
deal because this is a long-term lease
on a piece of real estate but then
there's a carbon developer the carbon
developer in the case of of the project
on the Connecticut Lakes Pro property
the carbon developer at the time in 2003
when the previous owner sold the carbon
was finite carbon still is because they
have a long-term relationship with
whoever owns that land uh the carbon
developer job is actually to put
together the project meaning the
contract terms to meet the requirements
of the third nested Circle which is
carbon Registries and I've got some
slides that show these things so the
carbon Registries are actually private
entities except for the State of
California and we'll talk about that in
a second that set the rules for how you
develop a carbon credit which is one
metric ton of carbon dioxide and you
know the Registries themselves outside
of California are generally unre
regulated these are private entities
creating these rules and then lastly the
carbon markets themselves are virtual
markets where the buyers um will will uh
essentially uh see what's available that
are that that's listed through the
carbon Registries and um have a deal of
some sort there's no set price it's a
it's a free market system so those are
the the various components of the actual
carbon markets and that goes for both
Forest carbon offsets and others as well
works that way yes Mr chairman is there
a carbon registry in New Hampshire no I
have a slide coming up that shows all
the Registries and they are uh they are
Regional uh or national in nature so no
there's not one separately for New
Hampshire so there's two kinds of carbon
projects uh or markets one is called the
compliance Market which is this slide
here and the time commitment in a
contract is 100 plus years so it's a
significant commitment that a landowner
needs to make in order to enter that
market today the only uh compliance
Market we have is as a result of
California's uh cap and trade program
for greenhouse gases that law passed I
don't know almost 20 years ago and so
that program actually allowed for Forest
carbon projects and other car carbon
projects outside of California although
much less so today than when they first
started doing this uh to to occur as an
offset in that marketplace where in
California the law creates uh
requirements of PowerPlant owners and
Factory owners in other words fixed
sources of greenhouse gases and so they
have to reduce those gases over time
just like uh we do with Reggie and and
other uh programs for a emissions and as
part of that reduction they can purchase
offsets not the whole thing but just
part of it and so that market uh is
actually the market that uh was entered
into in 2013 with Connecticut lakes with
the forest Land Group so
essentially uh the power plant owners
and Factory owners in California are
paying for the carbon on that
Connecticut Lakes property in Northern
New
Hampshire so that's a compliance market
now Washington state has has a brand new
law mired after California but they've
decided that only projects within
Washington state will be allowed so we
won't have access to that and so for the
time being uh the only place where this
can happen is through the California
resources board Market but again they've
they're discouraging Pro projects
outside of California as we go on Oregon
is probably going to be passing a law
and this group you all know what Reggie
is Reggie actually has a language that
uh would allow for offsets but the rules
are so convoluted that nobody has put
together a forest carbon project under
Reggie rules and probably won't unless
the rules are are changed so that's been
there since the beginning of Reggie it
just doesn't work so uh as I said uh the
compliance Market is where Connecticut
Lakes
is the uh the voluntary Market it seems
like the the slide I had for that didn't
show up here anyways the voluntary
Market is the second Marketplace
and the voluntary Market has no
government regulation or oversight on it
as of today and what is the voluntary
Market the voluntary Market is any
entity but mostly when I think about it
I think about large emitting entities
think about American Airlines and
Microsoft and Amazon and and those
categories and Banks uh big companies
that want to reduce their uh
emissions and hopefully they are
reducing some their actual emissions but
the voluntary carbon Market does not
require them to do anything they make it
made a voluntary choice to do so and
under those markets they can purchase
offsets and they they have been
purchasing Forest carbon offsets uh
quite a bit uh since that really got
going uh 15 years ago or so and under
those under that Pro program again the
registry set the rules but there is no U
there are no government oversight on
that and on on that there's a 40-year uh
commitment in the volunteer carbon
Market except for one small program for
small land owners which I'll talk about
in a second and that's a 20-year
commitment so generally it's a 40-year
commitment in the voluntary Market again
nobody's requiring anybody to do any of
that yet a lot of money is changing
hands and this slide has the money in
that uh the voluntary Market the last
full year we have data from about $2.5
billion dollar uh was spent on offsets
uh in the California air resources board
compliance Market was about 3.7 billion
these numbers are going up over time and
where the action is is in the voluntary
carbon Marketplace these are entities
again that don't have to do it but have
chosen uh to do it uh although the
property that brought on the bill that
you have before you is in that
compliance market so here are the carbon
Registries so the carbon Registries that
we're talking about for California is
ARB on the left side I meant I put
Reggie here because technically under
under the laws that you all passed in
the Reggie states there there is an
opportunity but it doesn't work so the
the Registries were really talking about
our climate AC action Reserve American
carbon registry and Vera so again these
are the entities that make the rules
that say what does it take to create a
legitimate carbon credit under their
program that could be sold uh these are
these entities that you know have been
around uh for decade plus now that
really set those rules so remember in
the Centric circles yes
sir thank you for taking my question can
I can I go back to the difference
between the voluntary and the compliance
Market yes I'm trying to get clear in my
head the difference between an offset
and a credit do the do those
play together with voluntary and
compliance Market yeah they are the same
when we say an offset uh it's the same
as a credit and we T we talk in terms of
metric tons of carbon Dix so we actually
talk in terms of metric tons of carbon
dioxide equivalent right so if you take
carbon uh in order to get to carbon
dioxide carbon is one atom no I'm not
I'm not a chemist but carbon is one atom
carbon dioxide is one carbon atom and
two oxygen atoms right so that that
molecule is actually 3.67 times heavier
than a single carbon atom right so we
actually have to to think about that as
we do it but it's metric tons tons of
carb carbon dioxide equivalent that that
carbon times 3.67 that we're talking
about that gives one credit or or one
offset same term good question sorry I
wasn't clear on that so the carbon
developers remember these are the
entities that help you as a land owner
meet the rules of those Registries these
are the ones that are generally
operating uh in the US there are a few
others they haven't done much I
mentioned finite carbon which is in the
left box we're we're large land owners
uh work with these these kinds of carbon
developers planed carbon worked with the
forest Land Group on the Connecticut
Lakes property back in 2012 to 20 the
end of 2013 to put together that project
uh the ones on the right side are uh set
up specifically to work with small land
owners and now so what do I mean by
small the ones on the left side you need
really 5,000 Acres or more and generally
probably more like 10,000 acres I mean
they have done some projects with 5,000
Acres but anything smaller than that
they're saying is small right so the
ones on the right side are the ones that
can work with small land owners even
down to 30 or 40 acres uh but the the
the carbon developers on the left have
been around for almost 20 years the
carbon developers on the right have only
been around for two or three years this
is brand new for small land owners I
have one crossed out there simply
because that one was there two years ago
it had a unique program that uh had a a
one-year contract people flocked to it
it started in the Deep South in the US
people flocked to it and then when they
tried to get their methodology approved
by one of the Registries right that set
the rules regist registry said M can't
do it does doesn't really create any any
additional carbon right and so that one
really went by the wayside so the two
that are available in New Hampshire
right now are Forest carbon works and
the family forest carbon program core
carbon supposed to be here by the end of
the year but those are the for the
smaller land owners Forest carbon works
in the traditional way in that they buy
the carbon off your property family
forest carbon program which is a joint
program of the American Forest
Foundation which is the tree farm
nonprofit that you're probably aware of
and The Nature Conservancy which you
probably are also aware of they actually
pay for practices they don't pay for
actual carbon they pay for you to do
something either not Harvest Timber or
reduce harvesting Timber as a way and
then they own your carbon and sell your
carbon in the market place yes sir
Charlie I just want to remind you that
because this is a presentation for
information purposes we have a hard stop
at 10 o'clock you bet yeah we'll get
through it I don't have too many more
slides I'm going to be going through
them pretty quickly so again the
Registries themselves are really set up
Ru setting up rules to do these five
things making sure that the carbon
project itself and and you change your
mind and want out of the program they
have stiff penalties not that you can't
get out of it but you're not going to
want to because the penalties are huge
you're going to have to pay back what
you got paid plus a lot more as a result
of that and then there's this issue of
leakage which I only will leave with you
which is the thing of all of this and
I've been working on this for years now
that kind of keeps me up at night and
that is that leakage in the timber World
goes like this planet wide I don't have
the slide in here but Planet wide we
have um data that shows very clearly
that over time we as humans are using
uh Timber at an increasing rate and that
occurs also if we break it down to the
United States so over time we're using
more and more wood so if we in fact in
New Hampshire or anywhere reduce the
amount of wood that's being harvested
it's going to get harvested somewhere
else maybe somewhere else in New
Hampshire maybe somewhere else in South
America but that's the T the issue of
leakage and whether or not you know an
actual carbon credit and offset credit
is it real if you're just pushing the
demand for wood uh somewhere else that's
the thing that kind of blows my mind and
I'm not really sure how that all turns
out the the programs and the Registries
themselves try to take that into account
so when you sell offsets you actually
put sell a block of them and actually
they're put into a buffer pool that you
don't get paid for and that that
accounts for when you have big forest
fires like out west uh or some other
natural disaster on your property but
leakage is a big deal issue so this
slide is just the the fact that and you
probably all know this this this whole
concept of these offsets is fairly
controversial and this is just a listing
of a bunch of press reports over the
last number of years where people are
really questioning the validity of the
these whole markets so quickly to go
through uh just to show you how this has
grown uh in North America in 2000 we
really had nothing in in the US and and
in Canada there was one project in
Mexico was kind of an early uh pilot
project 2005 and
2020 so you know it has grown over time
but more importantly what's going on in
New Hampshire it actually hasn't grown
very very uh fast in New Hampshire in
New Hampshire uh which uh has uh just
under 5 million Acres of forest land we
only have just under 200,000 Acres that
are under long-term Forest carbon
contracts for offsets that's you know
just over 3 and a half% of the New
Hampshire Forest land more importantly
what kind of growth are we having and
the second graph
shows that since 2013 when the
Connecticut Lakes project happened we've
had very little growth so the the blue
graph on the right side of this graph is
2013 and 20 today 2024 is the next one
you don't see a whole lot of change
because we we've gone from about
155,000 acres in 2013 to just under
200,000 in that whole time period in a
10year period right so we don't have a
growth that's going off the charts
doesn't mean it won't have happen but
it's not happening and and I'd say that
it's not happening simply because of the
price of carbon in the marketplace is
not enough to entice a lot of people to
do it uh because it's not bad but it's
not great and that's why we probably
won't have tremendous growth but it just
happens that we've got one big project
under a carbon project and that's
Connecticut Lakes so getting back to
Connecticut lakes with the last few
slides here so we've gone back uh
through and these data come from um
division of forest and lands
uh and from the previous the original
owner lime Timber that shows the Harvest
levels on the Connecticut Lakes property
starting in 2003 when lime Timber uh was
the first owner of that 146,00 acres and
you can see it fluctuates over time uh
at the end of this graph in 2024 is what
uh the current owner Aurora sustainable
Forest LLC is proposing uh for Harvest
level as time goes on uh more
importantly uh to put in perspective the
second slide shows that before the
carbon project which again happened
under the previous owner the forest Land
Group before that in
2013 uh so from 20 2003 to two
2013 the average annual Harvest on that
146,000 acres and change was 40,000
cords a year I'm using cords because I
think we understand that unit reasonably
well 4 feet by 4 feet by 8T a block of
wood right that's aord and so that was
before the carbon project after the
carbon project including that time
period that the forest Land Group owned
it you can see the red bar that shows
that the Harvest level level did get
reduced by about 25% to 30,000 cords uh
for that time period up until uh when
now Aurora purchased the land uh in late
2022 so you can see the changes over
time and the proposed uh Harvest levels
that Aurora has uh put forward and that
is why we're here because of what
they're proposing because as I mentioned
under both compliance and the the
voluntary Market you can Harvest Timber
and sell
carbon and here's how you do that so in
this graph here which is somewhat
theoretical uh think of the green part
of this graph being the standing timber
in 2013 on the Connecticut Lakes
property right so at the time they
actually went out set up permanent PL
spot where they measured trees and they
get measured over time at that time
there was a certain amount of carbon or
Timber standing on that property and at
the time they actually got paid for that
standing carbon uh on that property the
company back there this is public
information because this is uh through
the California program they got paid
over $30 million for that third that
standing carbon in the trees on that
property in
2013 that contract that they signed
requires them for over 100 years to
maintain at least that level of green
right at least that amount but for USS
grow and that uh other color kind of uh
off orange on my screen here is what
grows annually and so in a carbon
project over time you can get paid for a
block sum up front that you've got to
maintain for the life of the contract
right because you're storing that carbon
but you can also get paid for the annual
net growth or at least a part of that
because remember I talked about a buffer
pool so what's gone on since 2013 is
that the previous owner and the current
owners are selling carbon out of that
annual net growth right so annual net
growth means gross growth less the
mortality because trees die naturally
right so out of that these these
contracts allow you to sell a portion of
that carbon or cut all that Timber or
sell some carbon and cut timber Aurora
and the previous owner are going to cut
some Timber and uh sell some carbon um
but Aurora is simply choosing to sell
more carbon than the previous owner
compared to how much Timber they're
Harvest so that's really how it works
represent please use your mic please use
your
mic sorry when you say sell carbon you
mean sell more storage get paid to store
to keep more in storage really get paid
to sequester more that turns into stored
carbon correct right so out of that
annual amount they're able to do that
right but they've got to maintain a
minimum of that green for the life of
the 100-year contract uh but they can
choose over time to sell carbon sell
Timber or a combination of the bo of
both of those over time because every
year you've got a graph that looks like
this so that's really how how these
programs uh work and that's all I have
so hopefully we got time for questions
yes Mr chairman so the 30 million you
mentioned in the previous slide that
applied to the green section of the
graph standing carbon temper did that
$30 million all go out of
state well since the forest Land Group
uh is not dyed nor is Aurora domiciled
in New Hampshire the answer is yes y
that th those carbon revenues do not go
in state they go out of state to
wherever the the owner of the land
resides great thank you representative
Thomas has a question thank you um I
think I know the answer to this but um
do fruit trees uh take in more CO2 and
is there benefit to to planting more
fruit trees if so I mean compared to
forest trees yes I I don't really know
the answer to that it really comes down
to the leaf surface you know where the
photosynthesis happens so if a fruit
fruit tree has more Leaf surface
compared to a forest grown tree the
answer would be yes but obviously fruit
trees and forest trees are all varied we
get little ones we get big ones and so
really would depend on what you compare
it
to representative muns has a question
thank you um this this green level of
standing carbon um was that level in
effect when the uh in your in your
previous slide when the um car you know
the average after carbon project kicked
203 when that when that at the beginning
of that red line yeah was there a
requirement for the to have the green
amount of standing Timber be present yes
for for the next hundred years starting
with that red line starts and remember
this graph is not showing that stuff
right this is showing amount of harvest
over these years no so my my question is
so that that level has been in effect
for quite a while there was quite a bit
of harvesting happening prior to 2023 so
what
changed why why is there less harves
harvesting yeah so that's a decision
remember I mentioned the project at the
beginning was
171,00 Acres previously owned by
International Paper paper previously
owned by Champion International before
that that land got split into kind of
two blocks 25,000 acres plus 100 acres
to the state of New Hampshire the
private land owner has owned 4 6,400
Acres since then and the decision about
the Harvest levels on that
146,00 uh acres is really that of of the
private land owner which is now aoro
sustainable lands I will tell you
something this is a little bit of
editorializing but I also wore a hat
back then I did Consulting work for the
trust Republic land for about two years
I did nothing but try to put this
project together and I know that when
the conservation easement was drafted an
Edwards from uh then the Department of
Justice was the lead for the State of
New Hampshire when that easement was
developed uh the intent was that that
private land had one economic well two
economic uses but one major economic use
over time forever into the future and
that was to grow and and provide Timber
to the forest products industry that was
the intent of the easement in 2002 when
that was all negotiated nobody knew
about carbon uh project projects or
markets they didn't exist so that
easement was silent on that and that's
why we're we're at where we are now
because the eement says nothing about
whether you can do that or not at least
in a general sense and so it's the
private land owner's decision to reduce
Harvest and sell more of the carbon in
that annual uh growth that occurs that's
decision representative parshall has a
question chair of house um and thank you
for your testimony today very
enlightening um you were um saying a few
things about your concern about leakage
into other markets are these other
markets uh first I assume we're talk
about markets in Africa and South
America and the like are these markets
as well regulated as our domestic
markets as far as uh ascertaining that
they are producing what they're
allegedly producing right so in terms of
leakage of course if you don't harvest
in your property it's Poss possible the
property next door in New Hampshire
would get harvested right but could mean
that it's in Africa or some other places
where it's not nearly as regulated as it
is in in the United States we we have
laws in place to protect our forests uh
and you know other places in the world
don't necessarily have laws that are
strict maybe not in the EU but in other
places in Africa South America and and
uh Asia certainly don't have the kind of
regul regulations we have so yeah that's
a that's a good concern I have that
concern as well
well okay I'm going to use my Chairman's
prerogative here since we only have five
minutes left and ask one final question
and that is when all of these programs
were developed was any thought given to
how they might affect the existing
Timber industry in in New Hampshire and
was there any kind of
mitigation for possible damage to the
timber timber industry figured into the
design of these programs I'd say
generally the answer is no uh I will say
that today there's much more thought
going into that because they're seeing
some effects you know prior to the
Connecticut Lakes project we really
didn't have any lightning rod projects
around carbon that people were concerned
about because it was affecting the
forest products industry but the fact is
that it's based on the landowner
decision from 2013 to 2022 when the
current landowner bought this land most
people didn't know that there was a
carbon project on the Connecticut Lakes
property cuz they reduce Harvest levels
slightly but not in in the way that this
current owner is proposing to do so you
know we didn't really see that and this
project uh in the whole Northeast where
we focus our attention uh is really the
lightning rod one where it's truly
affecting what's going on in the forest
products industry we know now that in
fact it is affecting markets so back
when they created this remember this
stuff came really out of uh you know the
Earth Summit uh Way Way Back in Rio Rio
de Janeiro and whatever
1994 um and the cop meetings you know
this is coming out of worldwide
discussions around climate change and so
uh the concern uh comes down to the fact
that forests are the the most important
natural solution we have and so uh I'd
say that not a lot of thought went into
it when they started and created the
programs and more thoughts going into it
now because we're seeing the true
effects of it so it's a good question
thank you and it's a great segue into
the public hearing that we will resume
in two minutes and I want to thank
Charlie LEC for coming here this morning
and giving us this excellent
presentation and alert everyone to the
fact that we will resume our activity Mr
chair couple of minutes Mr chair over
here yes could could I just ask um for
the um the eyesight impaired such as as
mine such as me could we get a full-size
copy of this could you email it to us
yeah I'll email this uh there are two
other committees that have bills I'm
going to email it to them as well uh so
everybody has it but yeah great thank
you thank you I say something just a
little tip when you can't see something
you can put your take your phone your
camera and zoom in that's how I do cross
well
okay everyone please take your seats we
will now open a suspended public hearing
on House Bill
FN a bill relative to suspending New
Hampshire's participation in emissions
reduction credit programs for a period
of two years we know that the original
bill under that title was a
misunderstanding and a
mistake and that what we're really
talking about here is for Forest carbon
credits and its effect on New
Hampshire so we're going to start this
morning I do have the pink cards from
the last public hearing and we will go
through
them as we proceed plus I've received a
few new ones this
morning and we have two full hours for
this resumed public hearing so we should
be able to allow everybody to speak this
morning
nevertheless I would like to remind each
person who does speak to be as brief and
as Su succinct as possible preferably
keep your remarks to three minutes or
less and if you hear somebody say
something that's on the record you don't
have to repeat it when it's your turn to
speak what we're interested in would be
new and fresh
information rather than repetition of
existing
information so is uh representative Jim
Tierney
here if so Jim will uh will be the first
up this morning then we'll follow him
with representative Eman Kelly if he is
here and then we'll move on from there
and Joe Kenny the executive counselor is
going to arrive at some point I will
squeeze him in as quickly as possible
when he arrives so with that
representative tney it's all
yours thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee you have heard how the
sale of these carbon credits uh affects
the recreational activities and later on
you will hear how it will affect how it
affects Coos County and the
municipalities and the logging industry
right now there is no State regulation
of this activity new Hampshire is not
getting any benefit from this business
there is no sales tax are they paying
the business profits tax the business
headquarters is not here and what they
are basically selling are stocks
Commodities
transactions and with no income tax we
get nothing there either let me make one
point clear however I am not advocating
for either of those
taxes the market for these transactions
are handled in California where carb the
California air resources board is
directing that the leases on these lands
are to be for 100 years in order to
participate in their
Market let's go back to
1924 World War I is a few years in the
past next to come is the Great
Depression World War II will start in 39
and we are in it in 41 four years later
it's over then comes the Korean war in
the early ' 50s in the 60s it's War in
Vietnam and Men on the moon more war in
the Middle East 911 and war in
Afghanistan all this in 100
years how can we lock up our forests for
100 years when we don't know what is
going to happen also I don't know about
you but as for me I am not in favor of
California telling New Hampshire when we
can use our forest lands
again new Hampshire needs this 2-year
moratorium to figure out what will be in
the best interest of the state and its
citizens and if a plan is conceived
sooner than the two years then the
moratorium can end sooner thank you
thank you representative appreciate you
being here to elucid elucidate us on the
issues that you're trying to deal with
in this legislation I do have one
question that you said in your testimony
just a few minutes ago that Aurora
sustainable lands which is the company
that's doing all this carbon sequest
sequestration does not pay New Hampshire
business uh profits taxes or uh B
business taxes I didn't say they don't I
said uh are they paying the business tax
don't know okay well maybe you weren't
here when they were here at the original
version of this public hearing they said
they do pay those taxes they believe I
was here at that original hearing and I
believe they said they pay all taxes
they didn't specify any particular one
and they didn't specify any amounts or
what taxes they were
paying okay well we can get
clarification on that appreciate that
other questions for the
representative representative liwicki
has a question uh thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question and I'm
not sure whether you're the appropriate
person to answer but I'm curious as to
how this uh goes with current use and if
these lands are being removed from
agricultural forestry use would they
then be uh deemed to be moving out of
the current use well the way I
understand the current use there are
different levels of it uh depending upon
what you're doing if you're allowing
Recreation that gets you a lower one if
you allow hunting uh uh stuff like that
the uh ohvs snowmobilers you get a lower
rate if you're allowing everything you
get the lowest rate possible if you
allow nothing your uh current use rate
is a higher tax than if you allow uh
different things on there um right now
we know there's the easement on um the
property up at the Connecticut
headquarters we don't know if there are
easements on any other of the oim at 5
million Acres of forest lands here in
New Hampshire and if there are no
easements on them somebody can come in
and say okay fine any of the uh
snowmobile trails through there they're
now closed any of the H ohrv trails that
are through there they're now closed you
can't hunt here you can't fish here on
any of the uh rivers and lakes that run
through our property it's all done we're
caret okay further questions
representative Harrington has one thank
you and thank you for taking my question
so it seems if I got this straight you
want to pass a bill that would tell
private land owners who enter into a
legal contract with somebody else that
they cannot abide by that contract
because you don't like the idea uh it's
their property it's private property
where else do you draw the line you
going to start telling people what they
can do with their property everywhere or
is it just Coos County is going to be
controlled by the state what we're
looking for on this bill is uh time to
figure out what the state wants to do
time to figure out how you want to
regulate private property no trying to
figure out how we want to Reg
representative excuse me representative
Harrington this is not a debate we we're
just asking questions representative tyy
go ahead uh what we're trying to figure
figure out here is how to regulate the
business so that right now uh the
profits appear to be going to a out of
state why can't they go uh not
necessarily to a market in here but make
sure we're getting the taxes there is no
registry right now for what's going
on uh the current use where uh folks
that put their property in current use
that is a registry uh through uh I
believe dr's got it uh but there's
nothing for the uh carbon credits who's
put their property in who's not we're
not looking to stop anybody who's
currently selling we just want to put a
moratorium on any new selling until we
figure out what the heck uh the state
needs to do to regulate it and like I
said I'm not in favor of California
being the regulatory
power okay thank
you representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
you just mentioned that the idea is to
stop any new uh trading on the carbon
markets but as far as I read the bill it
doesn't say that it says suspend all
current uh trading so can you CL clarify
that I I do know in talking with the
other folks that have put this bill in
that new new ones is what we're looking
to stop anybody who's currently doing it
and like I said there's no registry so
other than the Connecticut headquarters
we don't know of anybody else doing it
if they've got contracts set up fine
keep your contracts going but it's any
new ones from here forward that we would
like to just put a hold on for two years
or less figure out what we want to do uh
up representative Ms has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question as
a followup to representative kaplan's
question and your answer um so if there
was any new regulations that were put in
place as a result of this two-year study
that you're proposing would would you
expect those regulations to be
retroactive and apply to existing
contracts
no
followup
followup so if that's if if that's your
answer does that then suggests that
nothing that we would do as a state
Aurora best answer to that is more than
likely yes
for the immediate time frame in other
words if they've got a contract already
in place uh through carb for that with a
100-year uh hold on uh the property in
other words that's what's going to be
done for the carbon if New Hampshire
then for example put in that okay okay
we don't like leases of 100 years we
would prefer a lease say of 20 years
okay it wouldn't uh they could still
keep their 100-year lease they just
couldn't renew their 100-year lease they
would have to follow the New Hampshire
rules when that lease was up of 20 years
in okay thank you representative for
speaking to us about the bill here this
morning I'd like to call next on
representative good morning Mr chair
thank you for allowing me to speak today
and thank you to the committee I'm
representative aan Kelly representing
Berlin Carol Jefferson and Whitefield I
come to you not only as a representative
of Berlin in the North country but also
as a member of a third generation
Sawmill that has existed in Berlin since
1945 I'm hoping that I can shed some
light shed some light on why this
legislation is important for our Vital
Forest economy here in New Hampshire and
why I'm supporting HP
1697 from 1990 to 2010 New Hampshire
went through the largest economic shift
in its history the collapse of the Pulp
and Paper industry caused the loss of
nearly 50% of direct jobs in the forest
products industry Forest Products fell
from over 12% of State GDP down to less
than 4% during that time no count County
felt that those losses greater than Coos
the impact of this Market shift went
beyond broad jaw numbers the loss of
Pulp and Paper plants meant loggers no
longer had a buyer for lowgrade wood
that represents the majority of New
Hampshire forests the dismantling of the
large plots of forest land accumulated
by Pulp and Paper companies led to a
system where work was much less reliable
for the logging
industry where before loggers could rely
on a single customer for yearly
contracts they now had to Cobble
together work from a number of smaller
sources these new selective cutting
practices and less reliable harvesting
have led to an increase in the cost of
Saw logs New Hampshire's remaining
Forest Products manufacturers have
adapted to this new climate employment
in the sector has remained relatively
consistent for the last decade an
exploding market for carbon credits risk
putting the forest products industry
through another economic catastrophe
carbon credits generated by New
Hampshire Forest have have been sold on
foreign exchanges for over a decade
their only recent notoriety shows that
they can exist alongside the Legacy
Forest products industry in fact I'm
very interested in how these credits
could be used for the creation and
growth of community forests I'm here in
support of this legislation because we
as a state need to understand how to
keep that balance the division of forest
and lands could come up here and tell
you endless statistics about Legacy
Timber industry they could tell you how
many acres were cut last year where
those cuts happened what species were
harvested where those logs ended up and
how all those numbers compare to
previous years at the same time the
division cannot tell you something as
simple as how many carbon credits were
sold from New Hampshire Forest land last
year while we may have some insight
through sales and public markets there's
a much larger voluntary Market where
there is little to no Clarity with
contract terms over 100 years and a new
push for federal government from the
federal government to expand these
programs to smaller and smaller Parcels
there is tremendous uncertainty about
the future availability of timber here
in New Hampshire resource availability
is the number one factor in Sawmill
investment we are only one year removed
from the best year of for domestic
Sawmills in decades yet last summer my
own New Hampshire's largest Sawmill and
one of the largest employers in coas
County had to shut down for nearly a
month due to a lack of available Timber
directly caused by the sale of carbon
credits I would ask for your support to
this legislation so that we can take
this time to properly study this issue
and hopefully chart a course that avoids
the second collapse of forest products
industry here in New Hampshire um I also
mention um as uh Mr LEC um alluded to
there are two other bills uh in front of
two other committees um both those bills
I sponsored
um they are attempts at a a long-term
solution um but I think it's important
to to realize that that both of those
are going to take some time um the
previous Timber tax um when it was
established took four years um to
establish and it's passed by a single
vote uh in front of the house so that
was a 1949 we haven't examined this
issue um in in depth for a long time um
so I think that getting the the
knowledge the understanding and the
complexity um and Gathering that all
together is going to take us more than
just one term so that's what this bill
do okay questions for the representative
representative n has one thank you I was
um I had bills being heard in Commerce
when we had the first half of this um
hearing so I missed it apologize um I'm
wondering it who um sold the forest to
the party in
California so the the carbon credits
that were sold on the carb Market were
sold by Forest lands group uh in 2012
that was the first large sale um the the
the continued sale they sold as Mr Le
showed on his graph there's that yellow
section every year that grows that was
continued part of that was being sold by
Forest Linger on the California Market
every year um this new company purchased
them um in 20 at the end of 2022 um so
that they like they're they're going to
continue to sell on that market those
credits on that market um but that this
is about 10% of their total land
Holdings Nationwide um so the rest of
their credits could be sold anywhere um
they may be sold uh blue Source the the
former name of of Aurora they have been
a project developer in this space for a
very long time um they are known for you
know working with other um companies to
sell on the voluntary exchange um so we
you know they could be sold
anywhere followup I'm not sure I'm
understanding because the forest itself
did the land belong to someone and they
and the party sold it to a California
company uh it's I mean Aurora I think is
based in Texas um but but they sold uh
the they bought Forest lands group in
all they they acquired them in all of
their land Holdings which totaled about
1.8 million Acres
Countrywide thank you representative or
vice chair Thomas has a question thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question so you alluded to it a little
bit um what effect if this bill did not
pass what effect would this have on the
tourist industry in that region um
because of the recreational
opportunities that may or may not be
taken
away I believe representative Le I don't
know if he's testifying today but but he
did submit testimony um and specifically
focused on the recreational aspect of
this um the I'm I'm happy to speculate I
think that we don't know what the
long-term impacts of this are I can talk
about the the worst case scenario um you
know the the idea so so beyond
just the the uh landowner agreements
that we that keep our recreational
programs running
um it's a lot of almost all of our our
recreational work is done on private
lands so those Agreements are at the
whim of the land owner if land owner
shift you know if if our you know land
becomes more valuable um you know we
could have new foreign land owners come
in and shut things down um there's
questions around soil erosion as Mr Le
alluded to the um soil is an important
aspect of carbon retention and so yes in
some markets you're not going to
consider the soil uh in other markets
they may and so you may be asked to
lower programs or like to um restrict
programs that could affect your soil uh
carbon retention and or you could sell
additional credits by proving that you
are uh retaining more carbon in in the
soil by you know not allowing people to
walk on the
land I just passed out a letter of
testimony from representative wette that
addresses the issues that uh Vice chair
Thomas was questioning representative
muns has a question thank you Mr chair
and thank you representative for taking
my question um you clearly there's a lot
that um we need to figure out um as to
how this affects New Hampshire um and it
seems to me that it would be appropriate
to take some time to do that my question
for you is uh why do we need to suspend
the sale of carbon offsets while we're
doing that that that work what why is
that so
important so my so as they've talked
about there are different markets with
different requirements for how long your
your lease is going to be uh in place
but if you're selling a 100-year lease
on a property you know the the uh I
would recommend you know if any of you
have interest in this um to listen to my
testimony for my other two bills which I
will happily email out to the committee
um they're each 15 minutes long so um if
you have some nighttime listening that
you want to put yourself to bed to um go
for it but the the the idea that we are
allowing a a 100-year lease on a
property or putting giving that you know
that that that's an option is that so so
we could quickly very quickly without
before we have time to act you know
large swats of New Hampshire Forest land
could be locked up um as Mr LEC showed
in his graph that standing Timber
section of the carbon
sequestration uh is a the large chunk so
that's the first chunk and that's where
you're saying you know the standing
timber that's there when you sell the
first set of credits that's you're
locking that up and you're staying above
that level from there on for the next
100 years so it's that first bit is the
huge chunk you know 90% of your credits
are going to be sold in that first year
that first trench um so the idea that we
can slow this down until we can have
something in place
is is that's why I'm supporting this
bill representative Harrington has a
question thank you chairman thank you
for taking my question there's been a
lot of discussion about land use as far
as snowmobiling uh and hunting and
fishing and so forth has anyone that
owns these massive amounts of acreage up
there shut it off to those
activities so so far we don't have very
many here in the state of New Hampshire
I think if we look at I'm sorry but but
in the state of New Hampshire is what
I'm referring to so yes but um so so no
none of those companies have said so far
the 25 oh
okay representative McGee has a question
I have several actually thank you Mr
chair and thank you um representative
Kelly for taking my question my first
question is are you speaking on the
amendment that we received in the last
hearing because I'm trying to figure out
if that is what we are operating from in
terms of what the committee is being
left with that's just my first Baseline
question yes I'm I'm speaking about the
amendment the I I will admit I've been
focused on my other two bills and
sheering those through um the I've been
allowing representative Davis um to to
be the the representable to be the real
head on this bill um and I I do know
that they've been running these things
by several different offices as they um
work on the language for it so um I
trust them and I trust that this process
you know that they're trying to do this
in the the best way possible for the
state follow thank you yes thank you um
I didn't even get to any of my questions
that was just a okay so um in Mr L's uh
presentation he made the distinction
between the compliance Market which
Aurora participates in for the
hundred-year lockup of of land and the
compliance Mark I'm I'm sorry the the
voluntary markets for which the leases
are 20 to 40 years um and we don't have
a registry so we don't know how many
people or how much land is currently
operating under those two different
types of markets but my question is why
the bill doesn't have any specificity
around that because my concern is that
the language is very Broad in in the uh
Amendment it says um it refers to New
Hampshire Woodlands that we want the
suspension for all New Hampshire
Woodlands which means that these smaller
voluntary markets would be affected by
this moratorium so can you speak to how
that would operate to not really
um harm the people who are using uh
those markets in order to make holding
on to their land
viable um yeah I'll do I'll do my best
my my as I said I I
um I've been told that this bill has
been run by several different
departments State departments that the
language has been looked at by by those
departments so the the the how it will
affect current owners and how it will
affect future land future owners I I I'm
I'm bowing to them to the those state
agencies I'm not a lawyer I'm not a um a
tax accountant I'm not anything in
particular um so I'm I'm really trusting
in them to set the language
appropriately I do think though that
although the length of the leases are
shorter um the voluntary Market is much
larger than the compliance market in
terms of the the number and complexity
of the of the of the the the voluntary
markets we should refer to them as in
New Hampshire or in general in gen I
mean in general in general there are
many many many many many more voluntary
markets than there are compliance
markets so the um you
know they are smaller in terms of lease
but they are the the volume could be
much
larger representative bernardy has a
question thank you Mr chairman uh so to
get a handle on this is is the first
step to just have a registry of all the
all the Timberlands that potentially
available for voluntary or compliance
markets and then we can we take time to
figure out what do we do to get get a
better handle on
this yeah yes I agree with that
sentiment the the question is how do we
get the that registry going right now we
have APA pa7 intent to cut so when you
intend to cut you put you go and you do
that uh you file a bill piece of form
with the state so you know we don't have
something that every land owner has to
file every year um with that so so they
could you know how do we gather that
info we do need to have some type of new
form or new process to do that yeah um
and that that could be the the harder
part and then what what actually
qualifies for that program as Mr Le
talked about the family forest program
which is you know you choosing to do set
of practices but there are less
restrictions put on your property um
because they're Gathering a bunch of
these smaller land owners together and
selling them as a single carbon credit
vers you know does that qualify if you
only have five acres or seven acres or
whatever in that thing versus a single
owner selling on a single Market you
know what who do we who do we ask to you
know where where where do we draw the
line thank
you as a followup to that question if we
put a check bark check box on the
current use form that you have to fill
out to put your property into current
use that said is your property involved
in a carbon credits program would that
be adequate to create the registry that
you speak
of thank you for the question so the
issue the only issue with that is that
you only have to file that current use
paper work once so most the over 60%
it's over it's a I've only seen the
statistic from 2000 but over 60% of land
in current use has been in in current
use for over 30 years so most of those
land owners have never filed the
paperwork they it was passed down from
the previous landowner or there they're
the still the original land owner put it
in current use so um the we do you know
for those who have their land and Forest
stewardship um they do have to file a
forest management plan every 10 years
that Forest management plan is something
that we could say we want to know at
that time that that that that that
you're going to sell car carbon credits
that you plan to intend to sell carbon
credits um because the forest management
plan is going to outline the timber
harvesting That was supposed to that
you're supposed to do on the land
the the again that's only every 10 years
so it would take us 10 years until we
had complete data and that's only on
land that's in for stewardship in Coos
County that's over 60% but in the rest
of the state that's under 30% so we
would only get a small subsection of
everybody um I think that the only way
that we can gather a complete data and
gather it quickly is by requiring
a new form or a new process for doing
that um uh just to add just because we
mentioned current use and um addressing
representative Lick's question from
before about current use um the the Cur
we currently Abate forestry in the state
through two two means through a Timber
tax and through I know that they hate
when I call it an abatement but current
through current use the both of those
abatements are abatements on your
property taxes that are we intend to
collect especially in this case of
Timber tax we intend to collect at a
later date we do not assess the value of
ttim of growing timber on a property
because we will get that Timber tax when
we will get that property tax when the
timber is harvested that's the town will
so both of those programs are born
exclusively by local towns so what the
loss of the Timber tax revenue is a loss
of property taxes in those towns and the
majority of the towns where Timber tax
plays a huge role in their Town budget
are towns where they're already property
poor so we're asking them to
further not collect property taxes which
will lead to higher property taxes in
those
towns okay I think I I hope that someone
who testifies later on will discuss the
possible use of RSA 79 colon 5 to
address that Timber tax issue
representative liwicki has another
question uh thank you Mr chairman it's
more of a followup but uh when a
property is sold they uh obviously are
records with the county the state and so
forth and if at that time one were to
determine that the property has moved
from current forestry management use or
Farm use into some other usage um would
that not trigger the current use uh
10-year back taxes and so forth if it's
land yes a land use change tax if if the
property had changed the argument is
that this isn't a CH you're not changing
you're still growing trees you're still
growing forest and so under the current
definitions in our state
RSA it's still Forest land I think that
current use the the law defines Forest
land and farmland but then it defines
unproductive land the third category
unproductive land is specifically says
it's for land where Forest Products
cannot be cultivated cannot be uh cannot
be harvested it says harvested so to me
if you are no longer harvesting the the
property then you are no longer you are
no longer a forest land because
otherwise they would have said
unproductive lands just anything that
that doesn't qualify as Forest land so
um I I think it's pretty clear in the
RSA and that's my opinion but again I'm
not a lawyer and I can't speak to
it thank
you uh representative Kaplan has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative for coming in um
we're we're we're tending to stray a
little bit into how to solve this
problem generally in instead of talking
about the bill so I I don't feel like
I'm going to be remiss if I ask you to
describe uh any kind of alternative
taxing uh structure that might actually
solve this problem so I I know you have
some ideas about that could you could
you describe those to the committee
thank you thank you yeah so my my Timber
tax bill um that I put forward is an
attempt to do that the question it like
as we mentioned there are number of
markets where these are sold they are
sold for number of years they're sold
with many different level you know
different ways to calculate what a
carbon credit is so it's an extremely
complex mathematical document how do we
boil that down into something that can
be assessed by a local assessor's office
especially when that person may not be a
full-time assessing official it might
just be you know um and that's the
question they actually asked when they
formed the original Timber tax same
question um my attempt was to say look
they have this document that they have
to file with a um with a private um
registry so like there is a private um
there is a business that they are
supposed to have a certifier look at
their document and show that they're
math checks out um we we take that
document we ask them to boil those
numbers down and put them on a single
form for our local assessing officials
they file that document along with that
that paperwork that they're already
filing to their their certifier and then
we use th that number to create uh an
estimate for what's going to grow on the
property over the length of their
contract we then assess that we give
that um we we take that number uh amount
of Timber that they're planning to grow
and we say over the length of the
contract you owe that to the town so if
that's 100 years or if that's 50 years
you divide that by 50 and you that's how
much you owe per year to the town the
the my bill specifically says that if
it's a 100 year lease or 50 years is the
maximum for that number saying that if
the length of the uh the crediting
period that's what they call it is over
50 years then OS at the the rate over 50
years assuming that you would have
rotated twice through the property or
you would have gone through the property
once over that 50e period so I'm going
to ask you to stop right there I find it
confusing that you're offering testimony
on a bill that's not even before us
sorry as a way of testifying on this
bill and I know that executive counselor
Tenny has come to this hearing room
twice now to testify on this bill so I
would really like to to uh allow him to
testify cuz he's a very busy man and uh
so would it be all right with you if if
you yielded the table thank you I and
I'm happy to stick around to the end in
case there are more questions thank you
I appreciate that executive counselor
Tenny sorry to keep you waiting so long
I know you want to testify on this bill
and I appreciate you being here it's
good to see you
sir don't forget to turn on the mic
thank you good to see you Mr chairman
and committee members uh just for the
record I'm Joe Kenny executive Council
District 1 uh representing um kind of
the three Northern counties um bnap
County and uh a lot of land um and this
topic is obviously uh very important
topic uh for my part of the state I also
was a 14-year legislator so I appreciate
your service uh I got a pay increase
when I went to the executive Council so
here I am and uh hopefully no one runs
against me next time I need that
um we're grappling with this I can see
the committee is really grappling with
this topic it's not an easy topic um and
we know we're reading articles
throughout the country the New Yorker
wrote a great article which I'll give to
the committee late last year on the same
topic but you know it starts with the
Kyoto agreements and talks about the the
various Nations that bought into carbon
tax credit programs and the availability
of that um but there's been a lot of
unsuccessful tries at this uh carbon tax
offset program and so it's a developing
Market if you will but for New Hampshire
on the executive branch of government um
we have no information on this this
program um in talking to the Dr
commissioner Lindy step um there is no
um way of assessing the carbon tax
credit uh program that exists in the
state and and as such we we create in
2022 about 3.6 million in Timber tax for
for the state across the communities a
year before that it was 3.5 million and
in 2020 it was 2.8 million so so what is
the impact well the impact is you know
the communities if if all communities
went to carbon tax credit programs we
could lose several millions of dollars
of Revenue at the local level cuz there
currently is nothing in place that
allows us to really assess the carbon
tax credit and bring it back to the
local community now someone had
mentioned about you know the statute
that talks about assessing growth of
land and that you know there's an
opportunity to do that in talking with
commissioner um Lindsay steep uh it's
only been done one time in their
recollection that was in um the City of
Laconia so for all intents and purposes
that alone is we have a huge gap on how
are we going to assess the carbon tax
credit and its impact now that's on the
Dr side now on the the forest and land
side um it would be nice to know which
properties in the state of New Hampshire
are involved in this program um there is
no one in state government in the
executive branch that can tell you who
who's in the carbon tax program and
who's not that's a very you know scary
Revelation in this sense is that you
have something in essence that has
climbed into the state for the most part
unknowingly that's having an impact on
your economy and I'm talking about our
you know harvesting you know industry
and you know the wood products we're
always talking about we've got a crisis
with housing what what do we build
houses with wood and suddenly we stop
harvesting wood in the state of New
Hampshire that's going to have an impact
on our housing market and the cost so to
me um that's another issue I think that
forest and lands can't really identify
who's participating in it and uh I'll
also say at the federal
level the federal lands are not used for
carbon tax credit programs the state
lands are not used for the carbon tax
programs or offset programs however this
is really really being driven by the
private land ownership but I have heard
via phone calls through the forest um or
the for society who own 200,000
Acres um they're interested in it and I
know that there are some land trust who
are involved in it uh who definitely
interested if they're participating in
it but I don't know um unless I ask
someone are you participating in this
carbon offset program so the question is
is should public lands in the future or
people who receive public taxpayers
money be eligible to use carbon offsets
I don't have the answer I don't think
the committee has the answer but that is
a dilemma that we're going to have to
work through as a state and other states
across the country are grappling with
this issue as well and if you look at um
um the federal law there is no uh
Federal carbon tax credit or uh Federal
carbon tax in the in the country at all
there's no State who has a carbon tax
doesn't
exist so we have to in talking to
Lindsay stear Dr commissioner we have to
figure out how to quantify it but in a
userfriendly manner because uh we know
that there's impact with insect
infestation we know there's impact with
Force fires and God knows we've had our
ice storms here in New Hampshire
so that would be another impact on
carbon sequestration and how to quantify
you know when there is a natural
disaster and what impact it would have
on that land and how to quantify how you
assess it so I can go on and I know
you've had a lot of great testimony I
can tell by the questions that you're a
lot smarter than you were the last
hearing um which is a good thing uh
we're learning as we're going but we're
all learning as we're going that's the
reality this is a tough tough topic but
as someone who grew up in the state
who's got a gut feeling something's aai
here something's wrong um I I listen I
have a lot of respect for the ESG
companies they're driven by this
ideology that we're going to save the
world and you know climate change we got
to prevent it and this might be a way of
doing it to offset you know pollution on
the west coast and using our East Coast
lands to offset that but I have to say
for the traditions of our state the you
know our lumber and logging Traditions
which go back not decades but centuries
we didn't do so well in the 19th century
we found out the deforesting Our Land
wasn't a a good approach but our forest
in the Northeast today are fairly mature
and so um we have managed to land well
through our our Timber industry we know
that cutting trees and selective cutting
uh is is a good thing and and it brings
you know an actual a rebirth to the
forest and and and actually sequestering
carbon actually goes on a lot quicker
when you manage your your Force but one
of the things that we did was we
educated ourselves like we're doing now
we went to the University of New
Hampshire we went to UNH corporate
extension how can we work with our
Timber industry to better manage our
forest the undergrowth you know our
Wildlife our Rivers waterways and we've
done an excellent job here in New
Hampshire I would hate to see that be
totally disrupted by this new phenomenon
called the carbon tax offset that
totally just bottles up our land for a
use for what it was intended for which
is to Forest it in a good way good
management practices and so that um
we'll be able to use it for uh our
Commodities which we need on a daily
basis so with that I I know you've got
my testimony uh from last time around so
I won't belabor
anymore thank you counselor we
appreciate you being here quick
question this subject seems to beg for a
study committee because there's so many
questions that need to be
answered but do you think that a
moratorium is also essential at this
point in time or do you think there
is sufficient time to study this
question get the answers we need before
filing legislation that has any effect
on this
Market well and I think that's really
the bottomline question do we need the
moratorium right now um if we don't get
everybody if we can't get everyone to
the table the answer is
yes if we can get everybody to the table
today and we want to do a study
committee the answer is yes but we have
to get the players out there who know
what they're up to they know what
they're doing as far as the the open
market with regards to this this you
know carbon offset um if they're willing
to come to the table now and let us know
who they are around the state and we can
eventually have Dr be able to go into
their financial form on a yearly basis
to know who's you know got carbon tax
credit program on on their land um that
I think um you know
having um the ability for them to say
yes then the moratorium um might be left
with a study committee but I think the
whole idea of a moratorium is to get
everyone's attention and get them to the
table um and so I don't know that answer
because right now I know there's land
all over the state that's involved in
this this program but you and I don't
know who they are and who's
participating and so I think they need
to come forward um and let us know and
come to the table but I don't know who
the I I mean this and I want to make it
clear there seems to be a focus on the
uh the Connecticut headquarters property
you know that's a it's always been a
public private partnership up there um
we have agreements with them so yeah the
state has a little bit more leverage if
you will with working with that
ownership but I'm just talking as a
Statewide policy I don't know these
other players that are in our state and
a moratorium would bring them to the
table real
quick but if we say they'll come to the
table voluntarily and you want to set it
up into a study committee to figure out
how we can work with this new market how
we can assess it and how we can manage
it as a state that I'm all in on that as
well but I think that that is the uh the
bottom line
question thank you appreciate that
answer representative McGee has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you um executive counselor Kenny for
taking my question I'm looking again at
the language of the bill which says
suspension of sale of carbon credits and
maybe you could help us understand you
keep mentioning Dr but the bill actually
says the department of cultural and
natural resources shall suspend the sale
of carbon credits and offsets from The
Woodlands of New Hampshire for two years
from the effective date of this act uh
so that we can uh so the general court
can develop a plan to properly regulate
such sale do they actually have the
ability or the authority to suspend
those sales because those sales are not
going through the government in New
Hampshire correct so I I don't
understand how we would implement this
if we pass it as it's written um I don't
have a clear crystal clear answer for
you but I do know one thing um when it
comes to a
moratorium um I would step into the
Attorney General's office and say which
agency that that moratorium um who who
should be the sponsorship of that
moratorium or who should have the
authority um or or the oversight for
that matter and I would just double
check with the Attorney General's office
on that because again you you're making
a a big leap when you set down a
moratorium so you want to make sure you
have your your ducks in line
particularly on the uh the chain of
that followup I have so many questions
um so the other piece of it again I'll
just refer back to the language that's
in um the amendment that we've been
asked to review for passage the last
sentence says if this act is deemed
unconstitutional any person who has
entered into a contract to purchase sell
or trade carbon credits or offsets
that was affected by the suspension of
the sale of carbon credits and offsets
may still be liable for any rules or
taxes pertaining to such
contract um so in effect what it's
saying is if we create a moratorium that
says uh that we will not allow credits
to be managed we are also trying to send
a signal to people who are participating
in the market that any liabilities that
you have as a result a as a result of
you know your participation you're still
liable for um so we're basically saying
we're stopping everything but don't
worry and I'm not sure that that works
very well with markets I'm just not sure
how this uh would affect uh all the
people that are participating currently
in that market so my way of looking at a
moratorium is the previous entrance into
the market are in the market but the
folks who want to join join you know the
market in New Hampshire under a
moratorium would have to wait until we
get through some of these important
issues so we can best manage this
program in our state and and to
understand what we're doing and what
we'll be doing in the future because
every state in the country most likely
is going through this right
now Mr chair yeah over here a point of
clarification where is this amendment I
haven't received a copy it was passed
out at the public hearing a week ago so
it's probably amongst your okay your
information somewhere I don't okay thank
you I'd like to move on representative
McGee representative muns has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you
counselor for uh taking my question um
it it it seems
um it seems that one of the biggest
issues and you alluded to it as well is
that um we really need to get our arms
around how prevalent this activity is
within New Hampshire um you you know the
executive branch much better than than I
do um and I guess my my question is um
what is per there must
be an an agency or agencies within the
executive branch that has a listing of
property landholders in New Hampshire
what is preventing the Executive Branch
from going out and just
asking those people whether they're
participating in this um kind of a
program or not well number one it would
be have to be a voluntary program and
I'm not sure some people like to
volunteer their
information um but with the current use
program out there that information is
already collected at the state level and
obviously because of Revenue purposes um
and I heard earlier that you know the
approach might be that we work with Dr
to say okay you're going to be the
agency that
identifies you know who is you know
collecting whatever whatever Revenue
under this um carbon tax program and
then you're going to be responsible not
only for collecting the data but also
administrating the um you know whatever
the assessing fee or whatever is
involved that's yet to be determined
what we're going to you know potentially
call it so but it's a collaborative
effort before um between force and Lance
and Department of re Revenue
Administration um as they do
collaboratively work with the current
use program so um it's going to take
probably uh two entities at minimum um
there might be a third but um to
administrate you know this program quick
follow quick followup make it very quick
please um so it so it sounds like what
would be um useful to move this forward
is have language that requires Property
Owners to disclose this information
which is not part of this bill right now
as I read it right um the you know when
I first said that I would show up here
today and support a moratorium it was
really to kind of you know okay let's
start from square one again and try to
look at these issues and create you know
a committee to review some of the
answers or some of the policy issues
that New Hampshire might move out in the
future on you know carvon offset
um it was not my intent to make sausage
here you know at the Committee hearing
and try to because I I don't think it's
a useful exercise because you know one
is you know we're going off in so many
different directions I think from my
standpoint if I were a legislator and I
have been one I would want to know okay
who they are have a list reg stre to
identify who they are number two figure
out how to to assess that okay and
number three um make sure that it's it's
a legal Market operating here in New
Hampshire okay and I mean that and I'm
sure that you know the the companies
will say they are and I'm sure they are
but you know they're registered with the
secretary of state and they're
functioning as an honest company here in
New Hampshire and and obviously you know
those would be the you know the three
things that I would want minimally out
of a piece of legislation
and uh as far as you know can we achieve
that in in a certain period of time the
answer is absolutely yes um but the
moratorium is to get everybody to the
table okay well I will defend our
committee and say that we are sausage
makers in
here we do this a lot but I want to
thank you councelor for thank much
testify I'm going to let you go because
we have 11 pink cards yet to go and uh
it's 11:00 so in order to get through
all these we're going to have to hustle
either that or skip lunch one of the
other which I don't personally favor
thank you so next up is going to be Don
Gorman The Honorable Don Gorman from
Deerfield who's here
to provide what uh I expect to be a very
succinct explanation of what the problem
is and a possible way to solve it thank
you Mr chairman and members of the
committee good morning and uh what I am
going to attempt to do is to give you a
baseline of what we are talking about no
technical jargon no uh information about
converting US Dollars into Euros or any
of that stuff this is what this bill is
all
about land rights Bob and Mary buy a
little cottage overlooking a Lake up in
Kos
County Mary's an anal
lover she posts her land no more
shooting bunny rabbits on Mary's land
simple that is a landowner's
rights let's move ahead to the next
points I have very very very deep
pockets and I want to buy
250,000 acres of land in New
Hampshire and I'm going to pay cash if
we can close the deal in the next 24
done I own this
land don't tell me what to do with it I
own
hunting
snowmobiles four-wheel
vehicles I will do it I have the right I
own the land
legally I really don't care if this
shuts down the Sawmills the trucking
Industries Mom and Pop's little grocery
store or the cafe in town I don't care
I'm here to make money I'm a businessman
I bought the land I paid for it it's a
done
deal we in New Hampshire cannot afford
that your constituents cannot afford
that I cannot afford that and my friends
and neighbors cannot afford that we
cannot buy New Hampshire and shut it
down that's the
Dilemma the last point is this this bill
does not do anything in regards to
regulations it doesn't say you can you
can't you shall you shall not none of
that what this bill
says we're going to look at all of the
angles which are very complex and
involved we are going to look at all of
these angles for the next two years so
that New Hampshire gets it
right we are going to Lumber and harvest
Lumber we are going to sell tax credits
and make money we are not going to put
Mom and Pop at the grocery store out of
business or the Seesaw sawmill in Coos
County out of business doing
it we are going to study this and make
it right that's what this bill does and
I suspect that we desperately need a
dedicated committee to look into all the
aspects of this bill so that New
Hampshire does get it right with that Mr
chairman pretty close to three minutes
yeah yes excellent I knew that you would
give us a succinct and compelling
argument about what we should do with
this bill so thank you thank you and I
will not take questions because it's an
overview either you buy it or you don't
but anyway in the spirit of time I'll
conclud pull it down thank you thank you
The Honorable Don Gorman all right next
up is
Jonathan
Frizzle of uh Coos count of Lancaster
Commissioners representative I mean
Jonathan Frizzle Esquire I sorry good
morning Mr chairman uh friselle friselle
emphasis on second syllable okay thank
you thank you Mr shamman thank you
members of the committee uh my name is
John felle I'm an attorney from wasac
friselle I my home is in colbrook I'm
here today on behalf of the Coos County
Commissioners uh who have asked me to
speak in support of this bill um let me
also state that in addition to
representing the County Commissioners I
also represent the towns of Pittsburgh
colbrook Columbia arol Lancaster and
shelburn so I have a rather uh diverse
uh Municipal client base within Coos
County specifically and I should also
add with with respect to the Pittsburgh
tract I hunt and snowmobile on that
tract
regularly with respect to the
information uh one of the questions that
uh the chairman asked about uh was
specifically with respect to RSA 79
colon
5 the RSA that suggests that if a land
owner is not cutting Timber uh what can
the local municipality do about it and
my frame of reference as I said I'm here
on behalf of the Coos County
Commissioners who are concerned about
the current
situation but also what situation might
be happening down the road what what
real estate closing could be happening
today as we sit here today there could
be another real estate closing which is
affected which these issues are
affecting I'm going to go to the example
of Pittsburgh uh I do represent the town
of Pittsburgh the Pittsburgh Selectmen
have estimated that they are going to
lose approximately $200,000 in Timber
tax from the land the
historical the historical cutting that
has happened in Pittsburgh on these
lands the Selectmen have estimated that
amount that they're going to lose that
amount um and although I am a strong
support of private property rights and
and of the freedom of the marketplace
these issues do have a a consequence on
the local communities and how it affects
the entire local communities tax base
and everyone's property rights put
together so with respect to the
Chairman's question on 79 colon 5 the
Pittsburgh selectman without revealing
anything that I would describe to fall
within the scope of attorney client
privilege generally speaking if we are
looking at that statute and because I do
go to court and I litigate cases
including at the New Hampshire Supreme
Court one question is what do we need to
do in order to use that statute well
first under the rules of Court going to
have to have some expert Witnesses it's
not simply enough for a select board to
say we're going to use RSA 795 and say
we're going to tax this Timber there's
going to be an appeal of that instantly
in order to litigate that case I've got
to have two expert witnesses number one
I've got to have a
Forester number two I've got to have a
real estate appraiser right off the bat
so the town of Pitts ber losing a couple
$1,000 per year in Timber taxes now says
to its attorney what do we need to
budget in order to use RSA 795 to try to
deal with this issue well we're going to
need $20,000 for this expert witness
we're going to need another $20,000 for
an expert witness oh and by the way we
ought to put your legal fees into the
budget also so now we're up to $60,000
$75,000 worth of legal and expert fees
to use a statute which which was
designed many years ago but was isn't
specifically designed for the sort of
circumstance that we're in front of
right now there's a court case and then
it goes to the Supreme Court we need to
tack on another 20 to
$25,000 for the legal fees and possible
other fees connected with an appeal to
the New Hampshire Supreme Court all to
try to figure out how can we use a
statute which is clearly on the books
but can we use that Statute in this
circumstance it's going to be a very
expensive proposition for a town to
mount that battle while at the same time
losing the tax revenue associated with
the harvesting
operations that's with respect to the
town of Pittsburgh with respect to Coos
County as I said the Commissioners have
asked me to testify today I thought I
would answer the Chairman's direct
question the chair the Commissioners are
more concerned about what could happen
with any of the other large blocks of
Timberland that fall within their
jurisdiction specifically within the
unincorporated places so I'm here in
support of the bill and thank you very
much for allowing me to testify thank
you I appreciate you answering my
question about RSA
795 representative Harrington has a
question so I'm thank you uh chairman
thank you take my question I'm so I'm
trying to follow the logic here it
appears what you're saying is that
because if someone decides to sign a
contract where they won't cut timber
down then the town or the municipality
will lose Timber tax money so therefore
it's going to hurt them so what else
could people not do let's say I bought
10,000 acres in Coos County and it had a
big huge mansion on it that was uh being
taxed at Value to 10 million the house
now I say I want to restore that to
Wilderness so I'm going to tear down the
house obviously now then tax base is
going to go down for Coos County
whatever town it's in so am I allowed to
do that or he'll say no no no you cannot
do anything that reduce your tax base
because that'll cost the town money no
that private property rights are still
extremely important the question is the
systemic effect the systemic effect
primarily from a large historically the
way that a large tract of Timberland has
been historically managed that has a
ripple effect throughout the entire
community and throughout that specific
throughout the uh tax base of that
specific Town private property rights
still need to be respected however what
this Bill calls for is simply a
moratorium to figure out how do we
manage that how do we manage that during
the short term while still protecting
stakeholders uh representative Kaplan
has a question thank you uh Mr chair and
thank you for coming in uh I know this
question's been asked before but maybe
you can maybe you can uh offer your
opinion as well uh from what we've heard
this moratorium will have little effect
on the on the current contract that the
large landowner that we're talking about
is is U you know holds the with the
carbon uh Market in California so can
you explain what the what the purpose of
the moratorium would be then if if it
doesn't really affect the uh the current
contract the systemic effect that that
we're talking
about what what is the panic and what
what is the hurry to to put in a
moratorium I I would Echo councelor
Kenny's comments that the importance of
a moratorium is to bring the interested
parties to the table right now we have a
situation developing where there could
be a closing could be taking place right
now which then has a ripple effect upon
the North Country economy and upon the
forest products industry generally as of
right now we don't know what's happening
and to and to Echo councelor Kenny's
comments it's important a moratorium in
addition to a study committee is
important in order to figure out the
consequences of that and to bring people
to the table so that we can better
understand the issue and what the
long-term consequences are going to be
if any of them need to be addressed
maybe they don't but what if they do
need to be addressed what are the tools
that we have at our at our disposal in
order to address
them representative Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair um you
stated that RSA 79 colon 5 is too
complicated and too cumbersome to use
could an adequate approach to this
problem be to modify that RSA so that it
is not as complicated to use and is more
effective short answer yes long answer I
don't know how it's going to cause a
any change in the Practical effects of
litigation in our current judicial
environment the the the rules that come
the rules of court with respect to
experts and the standards of proof
necessary in order for the town to mount
the
challenge followup followup so are you
saying that every
every objection results in
litigation so the example that just to
the example that you gave was it was the
council members the the the town elected
officials they couldn't go after this
company without getting I guess you were
talking about litigation though correct
if if if there's if there's if a town is
going to use 795 more likely than not
appeal and but if we could make that
appeal process easier for the towns
because it sounds like it's an outdated
RSA based on what you said yes okay all
right I think I'm all set thank you
that's the limit of your questions
anyway um seeing no further questions I
want to thank you for being here to
testify thank you Mr chairman and I'd
like to call next Mark Brady who is
representing the Coos County
Administrator and Mark is from Jefferson
Brady good morning Mr chairman would it
be okay if Mr Fel stays in case where
this discussion goes um get as close as
you can to the mic K can you hear me
there we go thank you uh first I want to
say thank you thank you for having this
hearing uh it's good to be back uh it's
20 years ago when I was on the other
side as a representative uh representing
the old District too in Coos which was a
huge District that went from Jefferson
all the way up to North Stratford over
to Dalton and Whitefield um and was on
the Commerce Committee with with John uh
John Hunt and we had a wonderful
committee and it's good to it's good to
be back here and uh so with that said um
I'm not going to add a lot of I don't
want to add redundancy I will say two
things for sure one uh and Mr Hackley is
here uh and I will provide to you a
letter that we actually sent to him the
cost County Commissioners did signed and
I believe the legislative uh our
delegation did as well uh which was
regarding the blue Source Aurora land
specifically the easement and
in that letter uh it's our understanding
that uh that uh Aurora is looking to uh
revise the the management plan on the
Harvest uh and it's our understanding
that that management plan the new
management plan that they want uh to be
approved by Forest and lands is is less
than the one that they inherited when
they bought the property obviously our
position is we do not and I believe
they're two years into that that I'm
sure Mr Hackley knows all the specifics
about this far more than me um there's 8
years left on it that was my
understanding we do not under any
circumstances right now want a
management plan uh approved that reduces
the Harvest uh you've heard a lot of the
the the the testimony because it does
directly obviously if it will affect the
taxes let me say this though and we say
it in the letter this is not just about
taxes it's it's not just about that and
somebody I couldn't see I was sitting
over here somebody said why why do you
want this why do you want a moratorium
the one thing that I hope is very clear
is this is a big issue it's a big issue
for the state I think that's what
counselor Kenny was articulating it's a
huge issue and it's not just about
attacks and replacing attacks on a
onetoone basis because I would argue
with you as a as an econ major from UNH
for what it's worth wisby many years ago
I would say yeah the onetoone
relationship oh no no no no no no if you
get rid of the if you get rid of the
Timber taxes and you get rid of
harvesting and you take Aurora at their
word and say we look to reduce 50% plus
our portfolio well imagine what you're
going to do to the North Country
specifically if you reduce the Harvest
with what's left of the industry up
there and there are people in this room
loggers that will tell you you'll if
we're at a threshold and if you go down
to a certain amount then you're going to
basically fall inen and purposes
collapse collapse the timber industry up
there and when you that's an ancillary
with what's left of us what we have up
there that it it translates and and I'm
not I'm not going to get into the
specifics of that but it's not a one to
one it's not oh we generate you know3
million5 million $10 million worth of
taxes and we'll just go figure out how
we can tax these car credits or this
activity somehow for $10 million and
then we get it back no because I don't
know what the economic analysis would
show but I guarante you the proper
economic analysis is going to show it's
more than just the the tax in the timber
because it sustains and supports a whole
a whole lifestyle whole
ecosystem the uh off-road obviously
Recreation uh etc etc what you were
talking about here and that's why it's
kind of like it's like I'm we're trying
to jump up and down and and flat our
hands to get the attention is that this
is a fundamentally different way to look
at our natural resource Forest that's
what carbon maximization is and I would
urge you
that you you can it's it's all there in
front of you if you go do some research
I wish I could do more for you I would
if I could okay because I've been in
your position and it's tough to be you
you don't have a staff you you don't
have people that you know you come up
here and and you you have to swat one
bill after another and you're dealing
with it it's a tough I empathize with
you but this issue here is a fundamental
issue for the state and it's something
that you have three legislative Vehicles
this session you have this one here and
representative Kelly mentioned his two
others so this legislature and certainly
this Republican leadership but this is a
bipartisan issue from us sitting on this
side up in Coos County it's all bipar
but I will tell you this legislature
needs to do something about it and why
the moratorium the moratorium because I
think councelor Kenny is absolutely
correct it will it will bring people out
but I want to put another wrinkle on it
I came home to become the County
Administrator last May May 15th I've
been down in Louisiana off and on for 14
years lived down there for 14 years I
was Bobby Jing's Deputy Commissioner of
administration which which is his
turbocharged om uh actually did the
whole BP oil spill with him took care of
his interest along with Garrett Graves
who's now in Congress we got a lot of
money out of BP on that too and they
deserve to have the money be taken from
with what they did okay but also my last
tenure was the last three years as the
under secretary for the Department of
Natural Resources in
Louisiana Louisiana was just so I worked
on a lot of this stuff I've worked on
carbon capture and sequest ation not
from forest but from injection where
they capture at the source and then
Louisiana geologically is is is is very
good to be able to inject it very
controversial and what I would say to
you is and I'll I'll end it what I would
say to you is that this is this is this
is Big Money big big billions and
billions of dollars money this is big
hedge funds Sovereign wealth funds that
are in this
and to be blunt they really don't care
about us up north our lifestyle it's
about aggregation of forest globally to
generate their numbers and they're very
smart people thank you thank you
appreciate those forceful
comments questions for Mr Brady
representative Thomas thank you Mr chair
um I just need a a little bit of
clarification one of the previous
speakers talked about a person of
property a personal um privately owned
parcel of property Somebody Loved
bunnies and so they they didn't cut down
trees they but they allowed public and
everything but then that changes to this
corporation that has large Parcels
what's the cut off is there a cut off
you're talking about that's a really
good question because I think that gets
to one of the hearts of this issue um
look as attorney felle said uh this is
all about property rights uh you know I
think Mr L is in here he gave a very
good presentation actually but if you go
to his website his business plan he
markets himself 2,000 acres or more and
he can help you generate carbon credits
that's what I think's on its website I
went and looked at
it what I say am I qualified to say what
that number is no I think that's a
discussion to be had I I don't want you
to lose sight of the fact that this
really is not about small private
property owners and it's not about
telling them what they can and what they
can't do I think the state needs to
understand the credit carbon market and
I've got right here I can leave it with
you here's California's air and Resource
Board this is it this is a scoping plan
you want to know cap and trade this is
what is here in New Hampshire right now
I think you the legislature and the
state needs to know that but what's that
threshold I think it's something that
needs to be to be flushed out but there
is is a distinction there's a very valid
distinction additional
questions seeing none let's move along
thank you very much for being here both
of you gentlemen that was a pretty good
segue to the next speaker who is Patrick
Hackley from the division of forest and
lands Mr Hackley
chairman
I don't know if I'll be a good segue to
that because that was some passionate
testimony there um thank you for the
opportunity to testify this morning
chairman Bose and members of the
committee um
I don't think my testimony before you
this morning is going to cover too much
of the same ground and I'll be I'm going
to read from my testimony quickly
because I know we have a lot of ground
to cover still um the Department of
Natural and cultural resources division
of forest and lands we do not take a
position on this bill as written but we
do have a few
concerns um just for some background by
the way my name is Patrick Hackley I'm
the state Forester and the director for
the division of forest and lands we're
under the Department of Natural and
cultural
resources um we're the state agency
charged with the execution of all
matters pertaining to forestry Forest
management and Forest lands within the
jurisdiction of the state one of our key
responsibilities is to protect our
natural resources for the benefit of
State citizens visitors and the forest
products
industry uh as we all know the we all
understand the Bill's intent here this
this morning is to suspend the
participation of all land owners in
carbon credit programs such as the
California car carbon emissions cap and
trade offset program which is perceived
to diminish Timber tax revenue decrease
Forest employment and reduce wood supply
to local
Mills however one exceptional case
between the town of Pittsburgh and the
state's largest private Forest land
owner who has decided to increase their
sale of carbon credits rather than
Harvest Timber well they're still
harvesting Timber but on a much more
diminished level is not a compelling
reason to restrict all land owners in
the state from their right to enroll
their property in such a
program a few other observations I'll
again trying to stay brief um for your
consideration the Department of Natural
and cultural resources does not have the
authority we do not have the statutory
authority to restrict a landowner's
right to manage their forest for any
such use or any use if such management
is in accordance with all state local
and federal
laws fair and reasonable land use
regulation and the availability of
alternate Revenue sources encourages
land owners to keep their Forest as
forests which benefits the larger public
interest at this stage it's too early to
determine as we heard from Mr LC how
many land owners Statewide are enrolling
or will enroll in the carbon credit
programs and what those impacts will be
I do understand what Mr felle was saying
about
systemic uh um Fallout should more and
more land owners enroll in such programs
we we simply do not know that right now
so to impose a moratorium on all
landowners across the state is something
that um I think is a is a real concern
prematurely suspending land owners from
participating in such programs is not
within our Authority as I mentioned and
even if it were legal to restrict this
right such a law may lead to unintended
outcomes possibly um over a two-year
period some Landers might say why don't
I just do something else with my land
that's not forested to to derive a
revenue Source if the state's going to
restrict on carbon credits what else can
they restrict me on so there's a concern
there that we have for private land
owners and the private Forest of New
Hampshire and finally I'll I'll frame my
my um my final point and then just a
personal observation the situation in
Pittsburgh between Aurora formerly blue
source that inspired this bill is still
unresolved under the terms of the state
held conservation easement the landowner
must submit their 10-year Forest
management plan to our agency for review
an approval although the land owner has
indicated that they intend to drop the
Harvest to half the volume of previous
years as again as the the graphic that
Mr L showed earlier uh they intend to
drop their volume in half uh compared to
previous years in favor of carbon credit
generation the State has yet to approve
their new revised plan to the and
compare that to the purposes of why that
easement was created U and placed on the
property and just I want to make a final
comment to those who may not know my
background um I want to address the
committee but also those who are in
attendants who support this bill please
be patient with the process as we review
the landowner's new management plan and
be assured that we are taking your
concerns and that of all stakeholders in
this issue very
seriously I began my long forestry
career in West Stewartstown over 35
years ago managing the same tract of
land the Connecticut Lakes Headwaters
and North Country Forest are ingrained
in who I am as a Forester
and that's why I'm in this position I
think it's part of the reason why I'm in
the position of State Forester today so
please know that I will do everything in
my part working with the other state
agencies to ensure that the letter and
intent of this conservation easement is
upheld thank you for the opportunity to
speak this morning thank you Mr Hackley
appreciate you being
here I have a couple of questions did I
understand you to say that a moratorium
could potentially lead to even more
development of forest lands by by owners
who say well if I can't sell car carbon
credits maybe I'll sell
houses in a two-year window it might be
considered a stretch chair Vos but what
I'm trying to get at is that if we
restrict land owners ability to do what
they wish with their land as long as
it's a legal use then it's one more you
know one more detraction to owning man
owning and managing Forest
land okay my more um serious question
here is about
the statement in your written testimony
that says the State has yet to approve
that plan relative to the purposes of
the easement what are the conditions
under which the state is evaluating that
plan right for approval thank you for
the question um so it's a very lengthy
document I don't know how many of you
have had a chance to review it but it's
one of the more complicated conservation
easements that are held on private land
in the state of New Hampshire but the
purposes and intent of a conservation
easement were to protect this land from
development number one so it would not
be developed okay that's usually the
intent of most almost all conservation
easements but secondly was to maintain
the land to keep it open for
recreational interests and that is why
the state when they negotiated the sale
of this when when the property was being
sold um that the state acquired 250 260
mies of gravel roads that that
um interlace this property so the state
owns the majority of the roads and
that's really a large part of how we
control the recreational access to the
land so recreational access was a key
provision the production of Forest
Products traditional forestry is also
one of the purposes of the easement and
that's really the Crux of what we're
getting at today there are no specific
metrics in the easement that say thou
shalt cut so many cords per year and
that and there in lies some of the the
rub here because of the the ambiguity of
the easement but it has purposes so
recreational access uh maintenance of
wildlife habitat and water quality um
continuation of traditional Forest
Products use again as was mentioned
before no one conceived of carbon
credits and that this would be a revenue
source for the land owner 20 years ago
so now that's why we're grappling with
it now but we see this as a balancing
act between the land owners's rights and
the Public's interests that are being
protected by the easement and that's
that's the challenge before us as state
agencies is to weigh how much of can we
find a can we find a a resolution
between those two um two parties and uh
a balance of interest that these lands
provide excellent answer thank you
further questions for Mr Hackley
representative Thomas thank you Mr chair
um when an two parts when analyzing
these plans first of all do you have a
time uh frame for this one to be
analyzed and secondly when you do
analyze do you include public benefit
and Community impact in your analysis
thank you thank you excellent question
um so we have 90 days to respond and
that clock begins ticking as of last
Friday we received a revised uh what is
called a 10-year Forest stewardship plan
so the clock ticks now for the state to
review and respond back to the land
owner and what was your second question
I'm sorry um when you're anal when
you're analyzing these plans do you
include public benefit and Community
impact we absolutely will be doing that
that is articulated in the purposes
section of the
easement
yeah representative parall has a
question thank you chair B and thank you
for your
testimony um I would
assume and and correct me if I'm wrong
but there's been some talk about a
registry uh for New Hampshire to find
out who's actually engaging this
activity would the uh creation of that
department it's a good question um it's
all part of the the overall discussion
um we have talked with some of the
legislators from the North Country about
the value of a registry so we know what
land owners are participating or intend
to participate so I don't know if our
agency would be the one um we do have um
to keep track of uh Timber harvest in
the state we do have a a portable it
sounds a little odd and and um detailed
but we have a portable sawmill Reg indry
all all people that have portable
sawmills register with our division uh
and that's just to keep track of the
non-commercial production of lumber so I
mean there's a means there's a vehicle
to do it whether we're the one or Dr is
the one I don't know uh followup
followup yes uh would you uh if it were
you would you need an increase in
Staffing in order to do engage in such
work and also uh could this information
be found within the domain of our
national Registries or or do we need to
have something done specific spefic to
New Hampshire in order to create this
registry uh first question I'd have to
give it some more thought as far as data
collection I don't think it's going to
be a significant amount of land owners
currently so I think within the
bandwidth of our state resources I think
we could do it um I don't want to commit
to that until I consult my staff but I
think we could pull that off and as far
as your second question about um if
there's in if there's another source of
this information besides having to go
through registry I doubt it I think it's
pretty much the wild west still when it
comes to what land owners are enrolling
with representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
heckley for taking my question um I've
had several conversations with folks uh
about this bill including um the New
Hampshire Society for the protection of
forests and we continually hear people
talk about it in terms of its emphasis
on property rights who can do what with
the land that they purchase but I'd like
you to comment on how much of um the
essence of the efforts here seem to be
focused on how we're managing our
resources in terms of a lot of the land
may be under downward pressure just
because of the value of the resources
right whether it's the water the land
the wood carbon sequestration so the
value of our natural resources is
something that's going
to be causing it to be carved up in
different ways right they're going to be
people who are looking to make money who
say the Northeast is a good place for us
to go buy large tracks of land so my
question
is do you have any sense of what the
state's obligation is or whether there
is a changing obligation in terms of
prote protecting the natural resources
that are being bought by private
entities for the benefit of the citizens
who live here because I think that's
kind of the Crux of the problem we're
facing
whether it's our industries that are
suffering or whether it's our lands that
are being mismanaged by people from
outside who don't have the same caring
for the land I I I look at it as a
resource issue rather than a property
rights issue and I I just wonder if you
could comment on it from the perch that
you have from this
agency wow that's a really good question
um I'll I'll try to Grapple it with with
as quick amount of time as possible um
so new H is in pretty good shape by as
we've heard today it's 82% forested it's
its land mass is 82% forested we we
collectively whether deliberately or by
accident have done a very very good job
of keeping our forests intact and keep
in mind also that 70% plus SE More than
70% is privately owned as you know
um about 34% is under conservation of
some kind or another 34% of those
forests that's that includes the White
Mountain National Forest all the state
land uh land use uh Land Trust Etc so
we're well above 30% conserved meaning
no development on those Acres that's
also a good thing when we get into the
discussion of land property rights and
concern about our forest we have to be
careful when we say our forest because
we have public forest and we have
private Forest but when you have a
forest land owner that owns large tracks
of
land 5,000 10,000 and in the case that's
inspired this bill
146,000 we start getting into the
discussion of public interests public
benefits that large tracks of land
provide so that's where the dance begins
with the private land owner and there
needs to be a a mutual agreement as to
what we're trying to protect and what
the land owner is willing to agree to do
for that let's say social license to
practice forestry um Recreation is a
huge concern for the North country that
is basically one of their economic
engines more so in some cases than the
forest products industry used to be so
when you get into large tracks of land
the public interest concerns goes up
proportionally and that's where the
state does and that's why we that's why
the state invested 20 years ago in in
purchasing the easement with certain
Protections in it that every landowner
afterwards that buys that land the
easement runs with the property to
protect those values
so I don't know if that answers your
question but that's kind of how I'm
looking at it from
now yeah I'd like to move on if we could
uh I appreciate you being here director
Hackley my pleasure thank you I'd like
to call next on Tom Thompson Mr let get
the perspective of the uh the tree I
just ask do we have the previous
Witnesses is this testimony in writing
you oh that's oh there it go there's
more copies over
here but we do have his testimony so Mr
Thompson
welcome glad to see you again and uh
looking forward to hearing your
perspective on this proposed legislation
thank you Mr chairman and uh I'd like to
read my uh statement into the record uh
Mr chair chairman Voss and committee
members my name is Tom Thompson and I'm
representing the Thompson Family Tree
Farm located in Orford New Hampshire
what I didn't have in this letter and I
will disclose today is that I I am a
member of the current use Advisory
Board I'm here today to testify an
opposition of House Bill
1697 and the proposed amendment seeking
a 2-year moratorium that would exclude
all private Forest land owners in New
Hampshire from entering into a contract
to sell carbon credits on their private
Forest lands we all know House Bill 697
is proposed because of one large Forest
land owner who owns the Connecticut Lake
Headwaters in Northern New Hampshire who
signed up for carbon credits while
cutting back on harvesting Timber
Products this is a unique property with
a state heeld conservation easement on
it it is not representative of the
thousands of private Forest land owners
in New Hampshire
I would question if this bill is even
legal say nothing about how upset
private Forest landowners would be in
our Live Free or Die state if they were
told they could not enter into a
contract of carbon credits or any other
contracts on their own land as a forest
land owner who owns 2400 acres in New
Hampshire and has freely shared our land
over 68 years to the state of New
Hampshire in the general public I would
have to reconsider whether we wanted to
continue sharing our land if House Bill
1697 were to pass my question to the
committee is if this bill were to
pass would you freeze the payments of
the carbon credits of the two for two
years with this small number of forest
land owners who have already entered
into a 20 or 40 or 100e
contract I encourage the chairman the
committee to do the right thing for the
thousands of small and large New
Hampshire land owners and kill this Bill
thank you for your time and I'm happy to
try to answer any questions thank you Mr
Thompson representative Corman has a
question for you thank you Mr chairman
and thank you Mr Thompson for taking my
question I'm one of your neighbors I
represent Lebanon yes sir good to meet
you um the amendment that we're looking
at says that the department shall
suspend the sale of carbon credits and
offsets from the Woodlands of New
Hampshire for two years from the
effective date of this act so as it
we've been told the way to interpret it
is it new sales of carbon credits would
be suspended rather than saying that
existing contracts would be affected in
light of that do you still oppose the
sir representative licki has a question
um thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question and this um I keep
coming back to the uh
current use which you apparently are
know quite a lot about but basically in
my mind current use is a deal we give
you a tax break because you provide a
benefit to the state to the towns
whatever um and if the benefit that you
provide is diminished then should not
your current use uh percentage uh taxes
go up so because you are not providing
that benefit anymore well first of all
uh the current
use was uh developed in 19 19 or started
in 1968 it took about 5 years because it
was a con Constitutional Amendment and
the purpose of that back then was
because we saw what was happening in the
southern part of the state where
development was Farmland was being used
for development forestry was being used
and it and it uh as we all know going
through the con trying to change the
Constitution is a pretty high bar to get
under but it happened and um in current
use you're assessing the land for what
it can
grow you indicated that it's a tax
um abatement more or less to landowners
it's not what it was it went through the
Constitutional
amendment was voted on by the people and
whether it's my farm land or if it's my
forestry it's assessed at what it can is
capable of
growing and
um I think there there's been some some
comments made about current use that I
think that uh anyone here or in the
audience can go to the Department of
Revenue Administration which we're
attached to and it's and look it up on
the website there's a handbook that
gives all of the rules and regulations
and I think it would be a might be good
if everyone did
that good suggestion thank you do you
need a followup
no okay seeing no further questions for
Mr Thompson I want to thank you for
coming up today and call on Steven Wood
thank you of Lebanon who may be one of
constituents hello I'm Stephen wood from
Lebanon and yes I am one of Mr corman's
constituents and I've known him for a
long time um I own uh about a th000
acres of land in Lebanon in planfield
and manage another uh 400 Acres of my uh
wife's family's land in
Dublin um and our land has been in
current use forever not that that's
gerain to this bill I am I'm sorry I am
here I'll pull it right over oh um I am
here
in turned it off it off you know maybe
somebody's talking to me
here I I am here in vigorous resp
respectful opposition to this bill I've
I've seen an amendment and heard what Mr
Corman just read it doesn't change my
view a
WI a a moratorium is an inappropriate in
New Hampshire way to do what you are
many of you write we must do which is to
know more about this entire carbon
sequestration Market as do you have an
interest in this we have an interest in
this as well people have spoken about
the program there is no State program
the only program that they're you're
really kind of being pushed to consider
is the one in Connecticut
Lakes American uh Forest Foundation who
are The Tree Farm certifiers they have
just launched with the nature
conservancy a carbon capture program
which is not getting very much traction
because carbon caps are starting to
smell a little bad in the state right
now but there it's a completely
different program I'm a small landowner
compared to a lot of the the the the
folks we're talking
about and programs like the American
Forest Foundation I'm only singling that
out because I know about their program
and it's just been
launched their objective is to get
landowners like me or 30 acre land
owners or 20 acre land owners to take a
more deliberate approach to the
management of their Timberland
to provide a a revenue stream that might
uh encourage them to hire a Forester so
they know better how to make decisions
about their land now again in the state
of New Hampshire which has always taken
private property rights very seriously
and in which it's the only state I've
ever owned land in um and I manage an
orchard and I manage a cery in an
orchard in Lebanon on this land that
this just is not consistent with the way
New Hampshire does or should do
business and I agree this needs to be
studied but I encourage you to consider
that we are studying it now as these
programs come out the landowners
unconstrained are going to be taking
very intelligent looks at all of these
all of these
opportunities and I've already rejected
some of them there there are some some
of these programs I would never would NE
never entertain for our land
as Tom Thompson said this is an
unwarranted restriction on my private
property rights keeping me from
considering for two years fair enough
for any time keeping me from considering
what's best for my family my land and my
community and my
state and I think you should consider
please with
respect that that sort of consideration
for the most part in America and
American in New Hampshire Timberland
Wildland Farmland
owners is is in pretty good hands right
now and including for the examination of
this sort of question so I encourage you
to find this bill in expedient to
legislate I encourage you to in some way
figure out a way to study this I
encourage you to I know you will be in
including uh
municipalities and uh forign Forest
businesses and other land-based
businesses please include landowners and
landowner organizations like the forest
timber land Owners Association foreign
Bureau and also some of the land trusts
and other entities that also have an
interest in all of our land like the
society for protection New Hampshire
forests and the Upper Valley uh Land
Trust I mean these are the these are the
people who are going to be considering
carbon C istration and that this market
and it's appropriateness to what we are
trying to accomplish that's all I have
to say thank you very much thank you
that was a excellent testimony we
appreciate it representative parall has
a
question thank you chair V and thank you
for your testimony today um the
amendment to the bill um says that the
moratorium will be uh uh effective in
order for the general court to develop a
plan to properly regulate such sale but
it doesn't not really outline how this
plan would be uh undertaken do I hear
you saying that you think a a study
committee a study commission or
something that effect would be much more
moratorium I yes much more preferable I
would abhor a moratorium under any
circumstances
sir representative Ms has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um I I shared your
concerns about a moratorium and I had
asked the previous uh uh person that
came up whether a a moratorium was
necessary um the response I got was that
it is necessary
because um you know what we what we
don't want to have have happened as
people during that 2-year period enter
into 40 and 100e
leases it you know the fact that that's
the those are the terms under which
these carbon um agreements um operate
does that create any concern for you
that you know we might by by announ by
by announcing that we're studying it
that all of a sudden there's a rush to
People by people to enter into those
agreements no I I and some of us will
just have to agree to disagree it's
it the moratorium is not necessary to
study and it may in fact be an
impediment to study it's going to make a
lot of us
angry and and it may incline some of us
to just say to hell with it I mean the
hypothetic I can't quite see somebody in
Rage going out and you know putting up
the shopping center on his Farmland
immediately and blaming this but it's
not it's just it is not necessary and
not appropriate as a as a mechanism for
Gathering people to uh to
to examine a question and and and to
assemble a
policy and in particularly in this state
again I'm sorry I keep saying
inappropriate but there you have it I
think it's
inappropriate did that answer your
question
sir okay thank you seeing no further
questions I want to thank you and call
Mr I thank you for the opportunity to
speak and as ever for your service folks
you're very welcome glad for you to be
coldbrook good morning Mr
Foreman don't forget to turn on the mic
right here right there we go thank you
folks I'll try to be be very brief I'm a
county commissioner selectman in cber
and as a county commissioner we have 23
unincorporated towns these
unincorporated towns are mainly Forest
ponds
Etc
and if this carbon credits thing is not
somehow come to some type of conclusion
where we can figure out how to because
it looks like the carbon credits at this
time could possibly uh definitely from
what I'm hearing reduce what forestry
practices we currently have the practice
that they're going to use from what I've
been told is going to be different
they're going to use a different type of
Forestry practice they'll use their own
Foresters okay Etc you already saw on
the graphs today where we're headed on
counting all right I represent from
Pittsburgh to Twin Mountain so I have
Mills I have all the guys that are out
there with the chainsaws very few
manymore I should say but you know all
the forestry equipment they have so we
need to keep these folks going if that
industry disappears if those guys
disappear to get that industry back is
it's going to be very difficult because
of the huge investment they have in in
equivet
ETC and it's a way of life for us up
there okay my grandfather came down from
Canada as a French logger so on and so
forth It's what we' do we've already
seen what the decreases are doing our
economics up there is is not good and
the other major concern here that I have
seen that I'm very nervous about is
whether these lands because you already
in Pittsburgh and I'm part of the
Connecticut River Headwaters but I am
not speaking for them I'm going to speak
about my experience on there is you have
an easement that was set up by Senator
Greg and Senator Shaheen and that group
20 years ago so these folks somewhat
have to work with us even though there
isn't told how much they're going to cut
but there is a forestry easement they
got the
workforce they had there is all the
other easements that are there now some
of our lodge tracks right now if they
get bought
up what leverage do we have they can
just buy them up put them in the carbon
credits that's it it's done they can
close our roads and and I mean Aurora is
saying that you know we will you know
don't worry your roads will be open Etc
I'm involved with the
ohvs The two clubs the Pittsburgh and
Cobra Club asked for a threemile road to
be added to the next year's group of
roads and trails that are open it was
taken out of the 5-year management plan
and I asked and worked with through the
folks and they said they would bring it
back but so I'm seeing number one huge
what it's going to affect our folks with
the decrease in logging Etc all the
other there could be a very s serious
problem here with the availability of
lands for recreation like snowmobiling
Etc all that so I think we need to be
protected at those areas like us that
are all these hundreds and hundreds of
square miles with just a few people our
whole life is from tourist industry and
that type of stuff and if it starts
getting limited and our forestry
industry disappears it's going to make a
significant impact on all of the North
Country thank
you thank you
questions from the committee seeing none
we have three more people who would like
to speak with us this morning and the
next one will be Steve
Hal of um
representing Milan Lumber not sure what
town he's from maybe Milan yeah yeah mil
thank you chair um
yes oh good morning my name is Steve
Holly I am operations manager of myland
Lumber in mil New Hampshire um I've
worked in the Sawmill industry for 45
years I'm Third Generation in The
Sawmill industry and the development of
selling Forest carbon credits has
greatly impacted the forest industry not
only in the state of New Hampshire but
across the US Forestry is one of the
oldest landbased Industries in New
Hampshire and if we continue to Halt
Timber harvesting a lot of jobs will be
at stake including employment at the
Mill uh loggers truckers Foresters and
many others that support the forest
industry Sawmill operations like Mile
and lumber are crucial because they
represent one of the most important
phases of the wood supply chain we
connect the conversion of raw materials
to Define
products um in the beginning of
2022 logging was significantly reduced
in the areas of the upper Connecticut
that Pittsburgh Stewart STS Clarksville
mil and lumber immediately felt the
blow without a consistent wood supply
our Mill jobs are at stake during this
transition from harvesting to carbon
storage this leaves a lot of us with
many unanswered questions such as do I
have a clear plan to support these
workers and businesses that go under as
the demand for natural resources changes
um do we have enough data to support the
carbon credits actually work are
companies just buying these credits to
look like they're taking action when in
reality are not even cutting
emissions um to conclude I would like to
say that there are many B benefits to
continued sustainable harvesting Timber
and selective Timber Harvest when trees
are selectively marked and ethically
harvested it improves Timber quality and
value resulting in a continual source of
income in a healthy Forest that is
maintained and lastly Timber harvesting
helps keep businesses like mil and
lumber and its workers employed our
everyday lives on these products
produced and derived from the wood so
this means we need to continue
harvesting of Timber into the future
thank you chair excellent thank you
appreciate you taking time out of your
busy day to come talk to us today
questions from the committee seeing none
I'd like to move on to our next uh
presenter who will
be William lavandis of rumfield Maine
Inc good morning and welcome good
morning uh my name is William lendis and
I'm a wood buyer for ND paper which uh
they own the uh paper mill in Rumford
Maine so my primary job responsibility
is to buy pulpwood for an ND paper chip
plant which is located in shelburn New
Hampshire uh in a typical year the
shelburn chip plant consumes just under
300,000 tons of pulpwood about 200,000
tons of that comes from New Hampshire uh
150,000 tons come from the northern
Three Counties and 100 sorry uh 100,000
tons comes from Coos County this wood is
harvested and delivered by over 30 new
hampshire-based logging companies as
well as by companies based in other
states who employ New Hampshire citizens
the purchase of the Connecticut lake
property by Blue Source directly
affected Shel bur's ability to procure
wood at competitive rates I saw a
one-third reduction in the amount of
wood delivered from the Connecticut
Lakes property with an even sharper
decrease expected this year while this
reduction is significant the indirect
impacts on overall competition for
pulpwood have been much more drastic
another other Mill that was more
directly impacted by this purchase
aggressively intensified their pulpwood
procurement from central New Hampshire
which forced me to purchase more wood
from Southern New Hampshire to
compensate for the Lost
wood while we have fully replaced this
volume it has come from land that is
much farther away at a much higher
average cost I'm much more concerned
about what happens if another large land
company starts managing their land
primarily for carbon in the same uh
manner as blue Source this would almost
certainly Force the closure of one of
the five remaining operating Pulp and
Paper Mills that procure wood from New
Hampshire which would have a devastating
impact on the timber industry and the
economy of Coos County um forestry
carbon credits are built on inaccurate
assumptions that do not deliver their
promised benefits Rumford and other
paper mills we operate because the
products that we make are critical
products that Society needs when blue
Source decides to stop harvesting Timber
on its land the world does not
correspondingly decide to reduce the
amount of our products that it uses
therefore we have to purchase wood from
sources that are almost always farther
away this means that carbon emissions
will increase for example if I have to
replace just one week's worth of wood
from Coos County with wood from Southern
New Hampshire the trucks hauling that
wood will easily travel over 20,000
additional miles to get it to shelburn
um and if we're unable to replace that
wood then other Mills and other parts of
the world will just increase their
production so I think the carbon the
carbon credits in Pittsburgh are not
free market commodity they're not a free
market product they're a compliance
mechanism for regulations passed by
California that were literally designed
to push the negative impacts of those
regulations onto other communities so by
allowing carbon sales you're seeding New
Hampshire's uh public policy authority
to California and to hedge funds so I
think you need to uh the state of New
Hampshire needs to figure out how to
deal with these carbon credits but time
is not on your side uh a hedge fund
could purchase another Land Company
tomorrow and shut down the timber
you thank you appreciate those
statistics on New Hampshire Forest
production do we have questions from the
committee seeing none I guess I'll thank
you and move on CH yes Tom
representative PL thank you CH could the
testifier present I'm
sorry
for I'm sorry present his testimony to
the committee written testimony is that
what you're asking for could you supply
written testimony I could uh email that
to someone I don't have
a I don't have it here with me
today email will be fine yeah what I
what I said is not exactly what I have
written
down okay send us what you got all right
thank you
okay moving on I got two last minute uh
late additions to our pink cards so now
we're back up to three even though we
were down to one
before so
uh lunch looks like a u a problem for
the committee this today next I'll call
today
good
afternoon my name is Ross Karen I'm from
gorm I'm a log buyer and Forester land
owner small Sawmill operator and a
lifelong resident of Coos County I speak
here today as a Kos County
resident um when I was trying to come up
with talking points for today's hearing
I found I had more questions than
answers so here are some of those
questions
what if California decides that carbon
credits are no longer valid and you've
got a 100-year
agreement what happens when a company
who has purchased carbon credits on your
land goes out of
business what happens if somebody
unknowingly purchases a property that is
encumbered with a carbon project because
anywhere recognizing that a lack of
diverse Forest Products markets is a
liability to land owners what are the
short and long-term effects on these
important
markets if large land owners get
involved with carbon projects what is
the effect on small land
owners if a large landowner makes money
on a carbon sale how does New Hampshire
taxed does carbon offset trading
actually do anything to reduce carbon
emissions and that's a that's a big
question I mean I've read hours and
hours and experts disagree pretty
strongly on that um the unregulated
carbon Market has many issues affecting
its
credibility uh why is Delta Airlines
involved in a CL class action lawsuit
accusing the company that relies on
carbon offsets of greenwashing over its
claims do we want unregulated big money
outside interest to control New
Hampshire
future I think uh representative Davis
recognized these questions he says
there's way more questions than answers
and um his intention is to slow things
down and try to do it right try to do
with the New Hampshire
way thank
you thank you any questions from the
committee representative licki has one
uh thank you Mr chairman thank you uh
could you give us those questions in an
email form because you brought up a
number of point that we hav't heard
before yes I can do
that we would appreciate that
representative parshall has a question
uh thank you chair V uh just as uh via
devil's advocate for a minute the one
question which I've been having which I
didn't hear not hear you ask is perhaps
uh the uh inability of the logging
industry to compete with these other
sources of Rec of income for the land
owners the problem with the failure of
the laog of the
industry in other words in a free market
uh do we really want to uh put our thumb
on one
industry well that's a that's a very
good question and I'm a free market type
of guy landowner rights type of guy I I
do have some
points name something that is completely
unregulated in this
country we talk about land owner's
rights but I can't Timber I can't do
timber harvesting on my property without
filing an intent to cut without filing
without fing following the laws uh we
have Wetlands regulations uh what about
the pharmaceutical industry what about
Banking and finance food we have zoning
ordinances building codes everything's
regulated why should this be completely
unregulated when nothing when everything
else
is and is it free market if it's coming
from the state of California that's not
really free market
okay good points seeing no further
questions I'll now ask Jason stock of
the Timberland Owners Association to
come and give us his perspective on this
proposed
legislation good afternoon Jason good to
here
Mr chair Mr chair Chris over here yes
Chris before um representative Kelly
leaves um is there an opportunity to ask
him one follow-up
question I would advise you to go out in
the hall and ask representative Kelly
that question and then you can give us
okay go ahead well thank you Mr for the
record my name is Jason stock I'm the
executive director of the New Hampshire
Timberland Owners Association and it's
good to be back in front of this
committee and it's good to be back not
talking biomass so this is
fun although this is this can be as
contentious as you have seen um our
membership includes land owners loggers
Foresters wood using Ms and this is an
issue that um we have spent a lot of
time evaluating and studying and it's
not every day that I have prominent
members and actually directors coming in
on a piece of legislation on opposite
sides which you've experienced today but
I'm speaking on behalf of the
organization and this is one of the
things that we bring to the table is we
try to get consensus on issues within
the organization recognizing that
Everyone's entitled to their personal
opinions or company's opinions but we
try to take a step back and look at the
industry and industrywide
um and and when we studied this we said
let's number one let's limit our look at
land use and the industry we're not
going to get into the the discussion
about whether Forest carbon credits are
an effective way to mitigate climate
change that's not our that's not our
thing we're going to look at impacts on
land use look at impacts um we don't
endorse programs We Believe land owners
have a have a right they can choose to
be in or out of a carbon program that's
their prerogative but we do think they
need to be educated and you've heard
today there's a lot of questions about
carbon programs how they're
structured um we recognize that stored
Forest Products as Mr L said do store
carbon this is stored carbon I'm sitting
on and and sitting behind and that
carbon program should recognize that and
lastly and probably most importantly
multiple use management is is is is key
for us for for Land Management good
forestry equals good carbon
management um and you know it's like
anything else too much of one thing or
another can create problems um one of
the beauties of New Hampshire is that we
have a lot of land owners and I'll get
calls uh regularly people asking are you
you know do we need a law to to to ban
clearcuts
um today we're looking at a moratorium
on carbon and my response always is is
that it's very unlikely that's that
everyone is going to wake up one morning
and say today's the day let's call
Chopper Bob we're going to we're going
to clear cut the back 40 New Hampshire
doesn't work that way we have different
land owners they have different
management schemes they have different
Management Programs they manage for very
different things and yes we do have
members in our association that manage
for old growth they manage for long
rotation Northern Hardwoods and they
they manage for Upland bird habitat
which requires a lot of early succession
habitat which you obtain by doing
clearcuts um but having said all that
carbon carbon programs can can work in
conjunction with sustainable forestry
and Forest management we have seen that
we are seeing that um and the uh two
examples we have a landowner that has I
want to say 15,000 Acres they have it's
a family ownership and so now you've
getting to the third generation where
you now have grandchildren kind of as
you know looking at this property and
they have gone from the the property
they've gone through the property doing
thinnings doing you know doing the
management and that prop property has
kind of hit a growth phase we've gone
through we've taken all the junk out um
and now for the next 15 to 20 years
we're going to grow
wood but you have folks that land still
has a carrying cost there's still a
carrying cost associated with that taxes
property lines you name it and so
they're looking at Carbon is saying wait
a minute here's an opportunity for us to
glean some Revenue at the same time we
grow our wood
and after that 20year contract guess
what we're going to have a lot of nice
Northern
hardwood ready for ready for Harvest
ready for the market isn't this doesn't
this fit well within our our scheme and
doesn't this fit fit well within that
family's kind of cash flow
process another example that I have is a
a a large land owner outside the region
they grow Plantation Plantation they do
Plantation forestry they have an area
Mill that's been telling them look we
want wood a certain diameter that's
really where our Sawmill really sings
that's what we want our customers want
that this landowner that happens to be a
real estate investment trust says I get
that but our our cash flow models tell
us that we you know for maximum
Financial maturity we have to harvest a
smaller diameter well guess what carbon
markets we can sell that land into we
can sell that wood into a carbon Market
grow it that extra
diameter we can get paid compensated for
that growth period and at the same time
satisfy a sawmill customer of ours that
really would like that larger diameter
wood so these are just two examples of
how carbon markets can augment or fit
within fit Within Forest management and
even satisfy a particular business's
needs having said that it it really is
unfortunate that we're having this
conversation in the context of what I
would say is an incredibly unique
project the Connecticut leges project
incredibly unique has a coner it's a
large it's a landscape scale ownership
has a con working Forest conservation
easement um held by the state of New
Hampshire and that when we look at that
project and we look at kind of the the
swirl of controversy around carbon and
as it comes out of that project that is
in our mind an easement issue and as you
heard from director Hackley there are
there's the letter and the intent of
that easement and that's really where
for us the rubber hits the road and so
to pass a two-year moratorium that would
affect that family ownership that's
looking to try a cash flow their
property during this growth phase and
and hold on to that land as Timberland
when maybe you have a grandchild one of
the grandkids saying geez we could start
carving some Lots off of this and make a
little bit more money um you know to say
all right let's throw out carbon let's
let's put a two-year stay on this you're
going to affect folks like that and so
that's why we think that this particular
proposal is is not worth pursuing now
having said that um and you heard about
the you know the timber tax question
795 um and I would agree that piece of
that piece of law is
complicated but we have very complicated
or complex solving uh tax officials at
the Department of Revenue I would say
you know one thing that could come out
of this discussion is directing the
Department of Revenue to do a deep dive
into this
we think when we look at 795 they have
authority but have Dr take a look at it
they have the tax experts they have the
timber tax experts and they can bring in
some Foresters and biometricians and
really look at how you do how would you
do this in a way that would not attract
the litigation that you heard about
earlier as for the
registry um and you'll see on our on our
talking points that I passed around one
of the things that we really want to
promote is transparency and we recommend
that you look at the registry of deeds
let's face it you buy a house you buy a
piece of land where do you look to see
if something's encumbered you look at
the deed and you go to the county go to
the county courthouse and so that was a
recommendation that we actually came up
with and so if you're Coos County and
you're concerned about how much land is
is going to be enrolled in carbon
programs you can go to Lancaster to the
county office and and check the check
the registry of deeds and that was for
us that's where we thought would be the
most appropriate way I recognize some of
these carbon deals in in these
transactions their contracts their
private
contracts um and there may be some some
elements of it that do not you don't
want to have recorded out there for all
to see in the registry and I spoke to
our our Council and said is there a way
to record a
transaction that doesn't really get into
the nitty-gritty of the deal and he says
it's done every day all the time and its
leases are recorded I think it's RSA 177
colon
7-a that's where leases leases are are
recorded um in the registry of deeds so
again you're not you're not providing
the lease payments the terms of the
lease all of that detail that you as the
tenant or you as the landlord would want
out there on the street but you're
recognizing that or you're you're
recording that that property has a lease
that property is beholding to a lease
that was done and therefore a subsequent
owner or God forbid a foreclosure they
come in and they look and they say all
right we're going to we're going to
foreclose on this property there sits
that lease all right there's a lease on
this we have to factor that in and so it
protects both parties in this case it
would protect the land owner it would
protect in fact it would protect the
carbon company but also it would protect
future land owners again the scenario we
don't want to have and you heard this
earlier Grandpa does a carbon deal kids
grandkids don't know about it the
property comes down to them and they
said all right let's cut some wood and
then they get a nasty letter from a car
deal saying you're in violation here are
some serious fines and penalties we're
coming after you again that's that's one
of our our
recommendations um that's one of our
recommendations in terms of the
transparency aspect of
that having said all that I'm I know I'm
between you and lunch and I apologize
but I wanted to just get our our
comments and our thoughts on the record
and I appreciate the opportunity to
speak and if there is a subcommittee or
a work session I'm happy to participate
and I can bring land owners and others
including Forest industry to the table
and we can have that conversation thank
you thank you questions for Mr
stock boy I did good seeing none well
you're really hungry you got off you got
off easy Jason thank you thanks a lot
okay the person who gets the last word
here this morning or this afternoon now
I had all the cards from last week I
don't recall seeing it I can do okay
thank
you and uh good afternoon thank you
members of the committee my name is Matt
Ley I'm the public policy director for
the society for the protection of New
Hampshire Forest um and I will be quick
we do opposed the bill um and we take
that position with full recognition that
these carbon markets have generated a
lot of concern um you know particularly
as you've heard about you know uh
impacts to the forest products industry
you know we think though the other side
of the uh argument here is that you know
they may be another source of income um
especially for the smaller land hose uh
land holders Forest land holders you
know those people owning 100 acres or a
thousand acres if it gives them another
source of income to help them manage
their Forest land we think that's could
be a good thing now um you know I will
also say that we certainly are not
opposed to any type of um you know State
oversight or state regulation of these
carbon markets I mean clearly as as
Jason mentioned there should at the very
least be transparency about what's out
there for these um but you know the bill
has written you know we just feel a
moratorium is a is a blunt instrument to
address you know what are important
issues so we really encourage you know
the committee to you know look at
different ways to address
these thank you um I'm Meredith Hatfield
with the nature conservancy and we agree
um with the forest society's comments
and I did just um want to mention that
uh it has been referenced earlier that
the nature conservancy and the American
Forest Foundation jointly have a program
called the family forest carbon program
to um provide some of these
opportunities that um Jason stock
discussed and Matt just mentioned um to
those smaller land owners so our program
is available to Forest land owners
between 30 and 2400 Acres the program is
just rolling out um it does provide for
a forest management plan for that owner
so our hope is that it would improve uh
Forest management practices and it uh
our program does not limit recreational
use in any way so whatever the landowner
wishes to do with that property um we
work with them to see if our program is
a fit um and if so it it would be a
20year contract and if you did um have a
work session or if this turns into a
study uh we would be happy to have one
of our experts come and talk about that
more thank you so I should say we do
oppose the Bill thank you okay thank you
so miss Hatfield the The Nature
Conservancy is the sponsor of this
family forest carbon program jointly
with the American Forest foundation and
they did file a letter of testimony also
in opposition to the
bill and is there a website where we
could U go find out about it yes what
I'll do is I'll follow up with my
comments and writing um to the committee
and I'll include those those links for
you that would be perfect thank you
you're welcome any questions for the
forest Society or the nature of
Conservancy seeing none I'm going to
close this public hearing and we're
going to break for lunch it is now
1223 we will resume our activity at
1:5 1:15 p.m. so we'll see you
then
for
please take your seats we're about to re
uh start our activity for
today next up is a public hearing on HB
dfn prohibiting the intentional release
of polluting emissions including cloud
seeding weather
modification excessive electromagnetic
radio frequency and microwave radiation
and making penalties for violation of
such
provision when we suspend ended this
public hearing last week we had 12 pink
cards from people who wanted to testify
and we saved those pink cards I have
them we're going to start with those
people and in addition to that because
we have received I don't know four or
five additional cards which puts us up
around 15 16 people we're going to plus
two more that I was just handed we're
we're going
to uh restrict everyone to three minutes
each presentation will be three minutes
or less so we will start with
Alex
Hampshire
now you've already spoken so I'm going
to let you go
last I'm not speaking I'm just
announcing this and leaving okay well
you've distributed it so that's all you
right
so did I get your name right is it
bordette uh bour okay thank you go right
ahead please three minutes if one does a
simple Google search for the word
geoengineering you get 300 million over
300 Million results of which
1,920 are videos uh if one does a simple
Google search for the word Chemtrails
you get
7,500,000 results of which 690,000 are
are videos during the last session I
attended with you it seemed to me that
some of you are question questioning the
reality of geoengineering I ask you why
would there be so much information
available on the web including footage
of planes spraying our skies that this
was truly not happening the aerosol
trails that they are spraying are
routinely turned off and on by the
operator this would not be possible if
these were mere crails these feet would
require turning the engines off and on
again during mid-flight I have eight
video links on your hand out there that
that show this
phenomenon Bill Gates admitted to a plan
to combat climate climate change by
blocking out our son using some of the
geoengineering strategies that have been
deployed for decades other billionaires
like George Soros Jeff Bezos are also on
board with these plans openly I have
provided you with printouts from
articles of both forwards. time.com both
very mainstream sources that are
reporting on this links to the articles
are in your handout just because our
military and federal government is
saying that they are not doing it does
not mean they are not doing it through
the Freedom of Information Act many
government secret missions have been
withheld from public scrutiny have now
now uh been released I have included in
your handout two articles that were
published in the New York Times one of
which was published on the front page of
this mainstream newspaper back in July
3rd of 1972 both these articles report
on the fact that the United States Air
Force sprayed chemicals in Vietnam to
increase rainfall this one secret of
mission was known as operation papey
both articles confirm cloud seating have
been successfully used as a weapon by
the US military also included in your
handouts are two pages over 53 page
document entitled weather as a force
multiplier owning the weather by by in
19 by
2025 this document was authored by a
panel of one Colonel two lieutenants
four majors 28 years ago table one of
this document under operation
capabilities Matrix mentions the
following capabilities precipitation
enhancement and avoidance storm
enhancement storm modification
precipitation denial space weather fog
and Cloud generation or removal among
others I have provided you the link to
download the entire 53-page document at
the top of your handout there have been
efforts by brave men such as Dennis
kinage former Cleveland Mayor
congressman and former campaign manager
for Robert F Kennedy who I've had the
pleasure of meeting as well as thanking
him for his efforts of trying to stop
this madness of spraying our skies the
bill he put forth in Congress 23 years
ago was known as HR 2977 also known as
the space preservation act this bill
mentions Chemtrails a term synonymous
with geoengineering in section 7 B the
categories are that categorizes them as
exotic weapon systems also listed in the
same section in chemicals biological
environmental climate tectonic weapons
which are also which he also sought to
ban with no avail while I do understand
the intended use for weather
modification during wartime used in
Vietnam I nor you should you accept the
such technology on the use of the people
United States by your own government
without allowing the people to write to
vote whether or not we want to be uh
sprayed or or have our weather modified
or whether we want our sun blocked out
thank you if you can read the rest of my
testimony and if I have any minutes left
over I would like to finish uh my
testimony well I have two problems one
we have a lot of people who want to
testify that's my there time all my
second problem is that you have spoken
for three minutes and you have never
mentioned the bill we're here to get
information about the efficacy of the
legislation before us it's right here on
your on your we're not interested in uh
uh hearing about things that may or may
not be happening outside the world we're
here to talk about Prov B it's not may
or may not be happening if you look this
is exactly if you don't want to talk
about the bill or any of the other
people who are going to follow you then
I'm going to have to gavel you as out of
order because we're here to talk about
the bill I am I if if you allow me to
finish when I come back I will talk
about I do not want you to finish thank
you I think we've heard enough that's
very unfair no it isn't it's the rules
of that the house that we are here to
get information about bills okay that's
what we're here for this is information
I just urge all of you to please look
through this carefully because it
provides absolute and un total
proof next I'll call on
Rebecca o kishin neski of Wilton New
Hampshire and please confine your
remarks to the substance of the bill
before
us
good afternoon my name is Rebecca
kishinevsky I'm from wton New Hampshire
and this testimony is in support of HB
1700 as a small scale hobby farmer
former environmental educator and also
as a mother and human being I'm
especially conscious about keeping
pollutants out of our water soil and air
I go to Great Lengths to ensure that
that the food I raise for our family and
Community is without contaminants it is
urgent that the clean atmosphere
preservation Act passed in order to
protect New Hampshire's air water and
soil for people wildlife and
agriculture the congressionally mandated
research plan document that you have
there on page six describes the
deployment excuse me development of a
government framework for SRM solar
radiation modification experimentation
such as stratospheric aerosol injections
sa the report States that SRM would
affect other aspects of the physical
environment besides climate such as
primary productivity due to land
degradation erosion of soil loss of
nutrients and biodiversity all
indicators of environmental health it's
important to note that the US is not a
signatory to the 2010 treaty on
biodiversity signed by over 190 Nations
which ban Geo engineering deployment the
treaty which remains in place was cited
in Mexico's ban to solar geoengineering
last year unfortunately our 12 F1
weather modification experimentation law
allows experimentation in the techniques
and methods for weather modification
this law must be repealed page 15 of the
Congressional document tells us that a
variety of unintended outcomes of SRM
are not well understood and there may be
others of which we're not aware
including among many sea level rise
patterns of climate variability ocean
acidification effect to coral reefs crft
production and ecosystems excuse me yes
could you speak about the bill that's
before
us I really appreciate that's all
directly related and important in
context with the bill sir but our job in
this committee is to to decide whether
or not the bill that's before us can
effectively deal with the problem and
unless you address how the bill can do
that then we we can't know whether the
bill is good or bad well it seems to me
if I may that the current policy allows
for just about anyone it seems if you if
I may the um in cooperation with the
federal government authorized agencies
of other states and with interested
persons and organizations it mentions
gifts it mentions um donations it's very
very vague as to who and how this could
come into play over our in New Hampshire
the policy is that we have currently it
is so vague and frankly dangerous and I
don't think that this is serving our our
people of New Hampshire and Beyond so
how does the bill help that situation it
for could you describe things in the
bill that you say will solve this
problem I can but I feel that uh
Representatives Pensa and Gard did a a
fine job of presenting that last week
and I know you've all had the chance to
take a look at the details with that
bill um I I would appreciate actually
being able to read at least the
conclusion of my
testimony well your three month three
minute time limit is up so I understand
that but you did interrupt to to I'll
you if we stand back and allow
modification SRM and SII to move forward
there will be no such thing as organic
food no clean air and no healthy soil
that's our
consent solar engineering solar
geoengineering and SII weather
modification are clearly hazardous to
our health to Wildlife and our
environment future Generations are
relying on us to protect our world from
pollution I urge each of you on this
committee to move this bill forward
thank
you thank you very much we appreciate
that
okay next up is Lisa Lipkin from Hancock
New Hampshire representing Clear Blue
Skies New Hampshire oh sort of or myself
oh I'm Gonna Give You My Testimony after
just for the sake of time I guess there
is no organization called Clear Blue
Skies New Hampshire it's forming okay um
so please tell us uh how this bill can
solve the problem that you seek to solve
well I would also like just go briefly
through my testimony um and I wanted
because the conversation is really about
governance of geoengineering and weather
modification and you you'll hear a
testimony if you you look at this
document you know that our government
has already created a plan for how this
is going to be governed and I just want
to say that our government this is
context for the bill our government has
a track record of experimenting on its
people without their consent or even
their knowledge you certainly know about
the Tuskegee experiments maybe you know
about the Cold Spring Harbor Eugenics
experiments and directly related to this
it should be noted that during the 1950s
under the guise of protecting us from
the Cold War threat of nuclear war the
United States Army I'm going to leave
out the details of the names and
everything it's called The Manhattan
Rochester Coalition we're spraying zinc
cadmium sulfide out of c117 planes that
flew from California to Washington and
literally sprinkled Radioactive zinc
cadmium sulfide across the American
Across America focusing on the cities it
was done with certainly no oversight um
this was done in the 50s to the 70s and
yet it was not admitted by the
government until 2008 when the truth
came out after many many deaths so yes
the military was spraying radioactive
chemicals on an unsuspecting public to
research aerosol behavior in cities here
we have the same thing we have our
government saying that they are going to
do
experimental research on us and we have
no say that's the bottom line legitimate
governance requires the consent of the
Govern of the Govern and as has been
pointed out in the state of New
Hampshire this is basically allowed free
reign I'm not going to repeat the the
bill you guys know it um what it does
say is that they um anyone who's going
to engage in weather modification has to
disclose to the public disclosure is not
consent It also says they have to
solicit public opinion public soliciting
public opinion is not consent HB 1700
must be enacted in order to protect the
people environment of this state you
sitting in those chairs for Better or
For Worse are The Gatekeepers your
decision making is of monumental
consequence and many many eyes are on
these hearings not just in New Hampshire
but all around the country and all
around the world legit legitimate
governance requires the consent of the
Govern please hear us loud and clear we
do not consent to this Reckless arrogant
experimental uh experimentation with
complex natural systems upon which all
life depends it is upon this body to
stand in the way of this going forward
in the state of New Hampshire if this
bill isn't perfect I know that
representative Penza and repres
representative Gearhart will work with
you to tweak it and make it as good as
possible and as Ironclad as possible and
by the way one last quick thing to the
person who mentioned CO2 last year last
year last week saying CO2 everybody
knows that CO2 is the cause of climate
change well I'd like to introduce you to
Dr Willie soon he is an astrophysicist
and a geoscientist based in SAA
Massachusetts and he said CO2 is the gas
of Life carbon dioxide is absolutely
essential for plant growth and all of
life volumes of research clearly
demonstrate that crop Garden Forest Etc
want more CO2 not less I in my testimony
you can look him up you can look up the
hundreds of scientists that he's working
with this isn't it's not a joke it's not
a conspiracy theorist and it's Theory
and it's not something you all want to
poo poo because it's affecting you all
your children your loved ones and
everybody that you say you care about
and that's my testimony thank you for
hearing it thank you next up is Melissa
Peterboro my vice chair has reminded me
that we discourage clapping and Applause
and other outbursts in the committee
room so if you don't uh if you can't
conform with that uh requirement then
you
shall I begin yes you shall begin okay
uh my name is Melissa white I live in
Peterboro I am
um I'll I'll spare you some of the
details details but um thank you for
having us today I'm here to provide
testimony in favor of HB 1700 I'm
grateful to our representatives for
introducing the bill the clean
atmosphere preservation act the White
House document of June 20123
congressionally mandated research plan
and an initial research government
framework related to solar radio
modification describes efforts to
establish a federal governance framework
for SRM geoengineering experimentation
this governance framework does not
include any input from the people of New
Hampshire and our elected legislators we
the people of New Hampshire do not
consent to whether experimentation
Congressional mandates or federal
governance of SRM activities page 43
paragraph two of that document says the
federal government conducts or funds
limited Research into SRM Congress has
directed NOAA to fund SRM research as
part of its Earth Earth's radiation
budget program for the last several
years this supports several
observational and modeling activities in
Noah NASA and with partner organizations
like the university um university
Corporation for atmospheric research
Noah Cooperative institutes blah blah
there's a bunch according to New
Hampshire state law 12- F1 whether
modification experimentation is legal in
our great state the law states any
department or agency of the state may
with the approval of the governor and
Council and within the limits of
appropriated funds or by means of gifts
donations or grants as already has been
discussed engage in and undertake
experimentation in the techniques and
methods for weather modification and may
cooperate therein with the federal
government with authorized agencies of
other states and with interested persons
and organizations it's clearly written
anyone can do this the last last line of
the law line C says the state will
solicit public input regarding the
proposed weather modification program or
experimentation soliciting public input
does not equal public consent consent of
the government governed is a require is
a requirement in a free Society it must
be state law 12- F1 must be repealed in
its entirety and HB 1700 would do
that again I'll I'll skip some of this
because you can read part of it but uh
we do not consent to SRM SI or any other
atmospheric
experimentation and as Lisa said the
whole world is watching this I've gotten
texts from people in Europe I've gotten
I've Got Friends in California and Ohio
and down in Florida they're all watching
this they want New Hampshire to be first
in the nation and um please pass HB 1700
thank
you thank you very
much next up
chipone I gave you all a puck just to
have because there's a lot of tension in
here and uh bipolar politics is kind of
not not helpful to anybody but uh I
agree with a lot of the testimony I'm
sorry oh
okay sorry I agree with a lot of the
testimony and uh I submitted one um well
I submitted four days of spraying over
my home in Salem New Hampshire um
noticing the skies are going from Blue
to gray um there's definitely something
going on and there is it is legal um I
believe it was made legal because
someone invented a way a New Hampshire
resident invented a way to Cloud seed
with some kind of a gun so they modified
the law to protect a local entrepreneur
I'm an entrepreneur and this is
something I designed and hopefully we
can come together as a as a people and
uh help each other's health I mean I'm
not going to get into this too much I
mean you guys have your job to do here
and everybody's kind of you know there's
a lot of tension in here but uh I'd like
to help educate you guys about any of
this stuff you have interest I have a
lot of knowledge of this technology and
other Technologies we should be looking
at and protecting the health of our of
our citizens that all I have that's all
I have to say any questions I'd be happy
to answer them thank you for your time
okay thank you very much next up is
Thomas
Deck okay Mr tampone doesn't appear to
be here so Susan Lewis is up and
deck no Susan Lewis either huh okay
Deborah
Chandler she's not here next up is
Hillsboro
good afternoon my name is Kimberly Lis
and I'm in Hillsboro New Hampshire thank
you for volunteering on the subcommittee
and having an open discussion with
concerned people of New Hampshire
regarding the clean atmosphere
preservation
act oh
jeez okay um anyway um I'm in support of
house bill 1700 FN the reasons are many
um there is no agreed upon policy for
governance concerning the atmosphere at
this point um we are not the only people
that are discussing this at this time
all over the nation and in other
countries as well there's discussion um
regarding governance and how to go about
it making decisions because they don't
know what the possible outcomes are of
spraying um
so there's there's unknown risks they
just don't
be okay um so I don't want to go through
all of this um there's a lot of
particles that they're studying if you
look anything up I have linked um the
White House um had a mandated report on
solar radiation modification so they are
whether they're testing now or not
doesn't really matter they are going to
test that's why this report was written
and there are many many reports written
about governance about uh SRM um so it's
going to happen it's in their it's in
their um documents that they need to be
able to have outdoor experiments um and
so by enacting this bill we could be
Sovereign over our land our Waters our
air um it
will it'll help to preserve our soil um
I do some farming I have a small farm as
well um and the the soil is becoming
toxic anyway and if they were to do
these experiments using um Nano
particles like aluminum which has um I
have it written on here you can see the
links um they're nanop particles and
they can go into your body very easily
because they're so minute they can go
through your eyes your nose right
through your skin and they cause all
kinds of problems that's written in here
and I've also made links that you can
look them up
um they're they're they're really
looking and when you try to look stuff
up to what they're possibly going to do
it they just name particles particles
it's very difficult to actually get the
list of what they actually want to do so
I think it's very important that we we
go ahead and this is a a great bill um I
think it protects everybody our future
here in New Hampshire our economy um
because you don't know what kind of
health problems this is even going to
cost um if we allow this to happen and
there was an accidental iron
fertilization of the um Pacific Ocean in
2012 that someone just dumped tons of
iron in the ocean to try to get Plankton
or whatever to grow to eat the oxygen um
they're trying to experiment right now
um Harvard I think I put a link in here
about Harvard's experiment that they
would like to run as well so whether
they're doing it or not they're going to
do it and I think this is very very
important legislation to keep our
sovereignty over our skies our
atmosphere our water our soil to protect
the health of all the life here in New
Hampshire as much as we possibly can um
with that there's a bunch of um links on
here that you can look stuff up I almost
went blind reading all this stuff it's
horrible to read
but I think it would be really good idea
if you would really look into it it's
not a conspiracy theorist Theory um the
Army and the government working with
local officials I wrote that in here as
well they actually already conducted
experiments on humans without their
knowledge so we don't we don't consent
to this experimentation that one's for
you thank you thank you very much we
appreciate
it next up is our
Linda McWilliams of Hillsboro and on
but okay um I'm now is Linda MC Williams
thank all of you folks for being here
today to listen to the concerns of the
people that you each volunteered um to
serve as our agents and substitutes in
um in our government um my understanding
from what I was taught in school is that
the purpose of government is to secure
um and I think that does not only do I
believe that that includes the right not
to be experimented on without
prior legally effective fully informed
consent free of any pressure whatsoever
that is um that principle is
incorporated a number of uh federal and
state uh statutes including the national
research Act and the Belmont report
which incorporates and expands on the
principles in the uh nurg code um I'd
also like to point out I mean you guys
have heard a lot already and you know
contrary to that line from movie instead
of don't look up look up any of us
who've been around for more than a
couple of decades can remember the
difference between a true contrail and
there's ample documentation on this
which is um you know simply condensation
of water vapor behind a plane that
disappears within seconds as my um my
significant other who's a pilot my uncle
two uncles one who graduated with Aunt
Hors from the Air Force Academy and many
others can uh can attest to um
referring more than once to the historic
context for
certain um you know regarding certain uh
aspects of our
Constitution and um whether or not uh
ious laws infringe on the rights that
are protected by the Constitution or not
and um in terms of the historic context
they refer to what was the tradition and
the practice at the time that our
Federation of States was founded and
when our constitution was written and
ratified at that time ownership of land
included own ownership of the ground
beneath the surface
and the air above to
Infinity um I do strongly in case you
haven't guessed support um
hr700
FN um I believe that it does a superb
job of if past of protecting the and
other rights of the people of New
Hampshire and their health and the
environment that we are all dependent on
on the CO2 one more comment how do we
get the air that we breathe the plants
take in
CO2 use the energy of the sun combine it
with water and some other minerals from
the soil and nitrogen in some cases from
the
air they create carbohydrates and
proteins and the byproduct is the air
that we breathe so the whole idea of CO2
being a um harmful element in the
atmosphere seems to me
uh like like a sad reflection on the
state of uh education in the United
States okay thank you very much for your
consideration appreciate it Robert
mlli M mclavy MCL is up
deck no Robert mccl he's sick he stayed
home because he's sick oh he's sick okay
sir he asked me to testify I was that
but I not okay next up is Bill lfi from
gilmon and on Deck is
Josie
kandala
good afternoon and thank you for the
ability to testify my name is William
lfy and I live in gilmington New
Hampshire and this testimony is in
support of House Bill
1700 I'm a retired New Hampshire law
enforcement officer and this unique
background has provided me the skills of
a lifelong and articulate investigator
with a keen scrutiny for
details moreover I have protected the
fine people of New Hampshire for my
entire Adult Career I now respectfully
approaching the honorable
representatives of New Hampshire to
protect me my family my neighborhood and
all of New Hampshire's citizens with the
power you
possess please help us cease and assist
the pollution of our atmospheres by
prohibiting the intentional release of
polluting emissions known to occur
during cloud seating weather
modification solar radiation
modification and Associated excessive
electromagnetic microwave radiation and
making penalties for violation of such
prohibit there is much substantial
evidence that this practice is both
ongoing and has been in place for
decades our own RSA 12f colon 1 weather
modification experimentation that was
enacted in
1985 clearly and succinctly states that
weather modification is known and
moreover the weather modification has
been ongoing and being conducted without
the people's
consent regarding 12f colon 1 weather
modification experimentation I will
refer to the White House document named
congressionally mandated research plan
and an initial research governance
framework work related to solar
radiation
modification as it clearly states that
the practice of weather modification is
happening on page 43 of the document you
will see the mention of
saber also on this page you will see a
list of the payload and which agency is
supplying each note that the date of the
document which is year 2022 and
2023 I will also direct you to the 2024
federal budget where millions of dollars
have already been approved for years out
in order to continue exposing all of us
our animals our crops not to mention the
wildlife to these polluting
interventions and
experiments the 10th Amendment of the
Constitution of the United States states
that most power and authority remains
with the states either with the state
governments or with the people
themselves as they determine in each
state the 10th amendment protects us
from the federal government's
overreach I have never given consent and
moreover this entire State of New
Hampshire never gave consent to be
exposed to this sort of pollution and
experimentation House Bill 1700 is a
simple matter of governance considering
that New Hampshire 12f is already in
existence we are very fortunate to be
living in the live free DI St pleas
Please wrap up okay uh in in in closing
House Bill 1700 is about pollution
intentional pollution created to modify
the weather consent that was never given
and governments that must now be enacted
I trust that all of us here want the
protection that this bill gives us we
must as a state come together and pass
House Bill 1700 into law thank
you thank you and thanks for the written
test Tony as well next up is Josie
kandala of Manchester and on Deck is
Melissa
Aus good afternoon Representatives my
name is Jani kumela um I go by Josie for
short
um I'm a resident of Manchester New
Hampshire and I've been born and raised
in New Hampshire my whole life this is
my home the granite state and I love my
home and um in response to your question
I'm going to focus my testimony um
specifically on what I support about HB
1700 um and I would like to direct your
attention to line nine um where it talks
about the departmental notice to cease
federal or foreign approved program
programs um the bill states that where
an activity that the Department of
Environmental Services has deemed
hazardous has been approved explicitly
or implicitly by the federal government
the Department of Environmental Services
sh shall issue a notice to the
appropriate Federal agency that the
polluting activity cannot lawfully be
carried out within or over the state of
New Hampshire pursuant to the 10th
Amendment which um uh the prior speaker
just U so eloquently discussed I think
this is huge um the purpose of the state
government is to create a check and a
buffer against overreaches of the
federal government and uh that this
needs to be um implemented as soon as
possible um similarly in lines 15 to 20
um similar language talks about foreign
entities that may or may not be
participating in uh solar radiation
management or other um geoengineering
activ activities um this is our only
line of defense at this point and it's
only a bill in proposal at the moment
but there is no discussion in this um
congressionally mandated research plan
written by the Biden Harris
Administration about any consent of the
Govern um any
um direct influence and uh due process
of law um surrounding this um uh agenda
um I could cite page 10 10 of the
research report that I understand um is
in your possession um and I think page
10 sums up the issue um very well um on
the first paragraph of the introduction
it says deployment of solar radiation
modification would inevitably involve
its own risks almost all of which are
poorly understood and some of which are
unknown this means that this is an
experiment um and it's an experiment
with significant hazards to human health
and to the environment um another point
I would like to um point out to the
committee is on page uh 32 yes of the uh
congressionally mandated research report
um discussing impacts on food and water
systems um it points out that um extreme
weather events including prolonged dry
spells and excessive rain reduce crop
yields excessive heat destroys crops and
kills livestock warming and drought are
projected to result in substantially
increased likelihood of multibreed
basket crop failures as soon as
2030 um uh if if that's my time um
that's my reason for supporting this
Bill yes you can sum up um that that's
okay great good thankly thank you for
Josie for your testimony because you're
the first person today who's actually
addressed the substance of the bill
you're welcome and we appreciate that
it's my pleasure okay next up is Melissa
economus or
makus and I apologize if I mispronounced
that's fine that's fine it's
understandable hi my name is Melissa
kakis and I'm from Newton New Hampshire
and I'm in support of HB
um due to the detriment of um the our
environment um our children our
grandchildren us um back in 2002 there
was a air for um a person who was in the
Air Force her name was Kristen
Megan and she was an environmental
specialist and what she would her job
was to do was to have everything go
through her that was going to be used in
the
military and um someone had come up to
her and said hey you know there have you
ever heard of chemtrails and she was
like No And she set out to debunk it and
she found that it was it was really
happening
and so she didn't sign off on the c52 is
and
they pretty much sent her to another
base they kind of threatened her and now
she's a
whistleblower um because what she found
was they were spraying the skies with u
barium aluminum andrum
stonum but anyway you can look her up
and also if you look up Dane Wellington
it's geoengineering. org
um he also has an immense amount of
information he's been doing this for
years um am I allowed to ask you a
question or no them instruction no we
ask you questions it's okay okay I was
just wondering I didn't
know um anyway I brought some pictures
in and um I'd like it if you could take
a look at them I took them you know over
my house in Newton and
um I also like put information in there
how to get a hold of how to look at
danne Wellington and um Kristen Megan
and where to go to look that up and you
can watch the dimming on that site as
well that's really all I have to say and
all I did want to say one more thing so
far I've seen all the people here and
all the people here in support of this
bill and you are our voice you're the
only voice that we have and I would
really appreciate it if you could listen
to us listen to our voice our
voice we need you to help us thank you
thank
you okay next up will
be
Terry hello
nothing but I came here
to speak about what was said last
week uh in reference to the government
and the intentional um
geoengineering
so jp5 and
jp8 are geoengineering with or without
consent and they're going to keep doing
it
on I think this bill is
important but it needs to be
revised there is a a a vast private
sector for
instance of
course uh well for instance the teleride
ski area has done on this in 2012 it's
been happening since 2007 I don't know
of any actual cloud seeding projects
past the Mississippi River
since
but as far
like people for hire and and the private
like a private company
they have full reain they can do
this how I've I've heard of people
wanting nice weather on their on their
um wedding and they have full legal
right to do so so I think the bill
should be revised away from trying to
stop government from doing something
because that's a a lot harder but what's
important I think um is is the private
sector I also wanted to plug Jim Lee
with climate view.org he's a a a
tremendously
useful resource um as far as learning
about the reality and sifting through
the fake and the fear and the things
that don't matter and things that can't
be
changed so with
that I leave you I had nothing this I I
came here just randomly I heard about it
yesterday so here I am uh trying to be a
part of History I guess and uh hopefully
it goes through and and we all learn
something and
um yeah a bit a good day thank you we
appreciate you adding your voice to the
chorus thank you very much next up is
Newport hi um I'm Risa Evans from
kukuk um and I want to thank you all for
Contin continuing the hearing to today
so that more people had a chance to
speak and also to the sponsors of this
bill for raising this really important
topic um I support the premises that
underly HB
I think that um
geoengineering um experimental
geoengineering poses a real and present
threat to New Hampshire and whether you
think it's already happening or it's
sort of in the air and on the horizon
it's really something that we need to be
thinking about um and we don't have any
laws in place that protect us or that
provide any kind of bulwark for what may
be coming down the pike and I know
there's been a lot of reference to this
report which sort of outlines the
governance plan that really has no place
for the states um I wanted to speak
specifically about our existing law um
about weather modification
experimentation and urge that at a
minimum you repeal this law which really
invites disaster um this is a law that
allows anybody to come in and partner
with a state agency and with the
approval of the executive Council and
the governor to conduct weather
modification experiments do they have to
show that the experiments are safe or
that the benefits outweigh the risks no
there's no requirement of that are there
any standards any safety standards that
govern the approval process is there
even any approval process at all for for
this bill for I mean for this law for
weather modification there's no approval
process there's no method for Meaningful
public input there's no method for
Meaningful public consent and this bill
really says nothing about what happens
if there are activities of this sort
conducted in the state and people are
injured property is injured there's no
recourse offered here and so I think
that this statute is really really sort
of a danger to have on the books and at
a minimum we should get rid of it put
all this stuff on hold um prohibit it um
until we can study it further so I I
would just urge that you know if if this
bill um seems to you unworkable in any
way you know I'm sure the Reps who
sponsored it will work with you to make
it sort of something that that seems
more manageable but at a minimum you
know let's let's get um RSA 12 F1 off
the books and replace it with something
that if it's going to allow any
activities of this sort that really
enables the people of New Hampshire to
meaningfully um regulate such activities
and to participate in the process of
governing those activities and only to
have them occur with our informed
consent thank you
you thank you appreciate you being being
here today next up is Michelle Whitmer
stratum so good afternoon
Representatives I appreciate you taking
the time to let us voice our opinions um
I support hb17
FN and as you already know I'm Michelle
Whitmer from Newport um Josie said it
best as to why this bill needs to be
passed I would like to offer to you so I
am in support of the bill and for every
reason the Josie has mentioned so
eloquently so I learned of this hearing
last night but I wanted to make sure um
you had some knowledge we have a small
Farm we're a nano Farm we have multiple
apple pear peach cherry trees we have um
an a half an acre that we dedicate to
our community in Newport for veterans
the elderly and those who can't afford
to have um fresh vegetables and fruit
we've had Farm camps with children that
we try to teach how to grow and
understand nature and how to live off it
um we have seen some major impacts with
what we um are experiencing with the jro
engineering
Chemtrails um also we do have cows goats
a horse chickens and turkeys so it's not
just um and and 8 be hives so it's not
that we just simply have Orchards and
Gardens we have it all okay we want to
be a self-sufficient Nano farm and so we
know that aluminum particulates are
being sprayed in the Chemtrails we know
that it is higher than levels which are
safe for humans but it also is having an
impact on our trees and on our animals
and our water supply um nanop particles
so what happens with aluminum changes
the soil composition some plants such as
blackberries tomato plants um certain
trees such as the balsams and Evergreens
require um an not the alkaline state it
would be the acidic the acidic what is
happening with the aluminums as it's
breaking down into our soil and also in
our water by the way but with our soil
it is turning our acidic state to an
um a ph and alkaline so we are losing
some of our trees and you can see some
of this in California with the Conifer
trees which are just similar to our
Balsam if you look up and you start
seeing these these trees that require
the acidity they're giving their one
last push in their in their
tree the Chute is dead the branches are
dead the very tip you will see still
alive and that's the last tip to for
propagation within our our trees they're
telling you something and if you don't
know it I'm telling you now it is
happening we are losing some of our
vegetation we are losing our soils that
allow us to grow product for our
consumers and for yourselves you have
masks on Nano particulates in the air
can go through those masks and the blood
barrier it goes through as you inhale
the smaller the Nano particle the more
dangerous it is we have Plastics we have
Al we have the aluminums and we have
borium you are breathing it in and it is
going through your lungs into your heart
crossing your blood barrier even into
your brain I in my my field is not
farming that we do for fun we have an
intimate relationship with our farm and
it's fun I am more on the health field
and the increase of dementia uh
Parkinson's all these neurological
disorders are increasing because we are
taking that aluminum into our brain we
are not given consent for this to to be
pushed into our lungs with every breath
we take that is not our consent and I
was 11 years old when the 1985 bill was
passed and I certainly wasn't given
consent then either and I do expect as
our Representatives that if you don't
believe in this bill then fine you have
no Pro you should have no problem
passing it because if it's not real to
you then what harm would it do it needs
to be passed I have more
neurodivergent um family members and I
do believe it has to do with the
Chemtrails we can see the Chemtrails
have different masses you can tell when
the Chemtrails are being
sprayed what's going to happen next my
husband knows it well enough where he'll
be like baby get your chores done
because in an hour if you look at these
Trails coming over on the east we're
going to start having Wind And by
tomorrow we're going to have rain we
have seen Vibrant Plants on our farm
spraying done on a Sunday and by Monday
had mildew and mold on them to where you
couldn't even the plants were fried they
were
useless we are going our farm is going
to the part to a point now where we are
planting indoors
only our birds are indoors only
and we're when is this going to stop it
needs to start here and my
recommendation to you to add to the bill
if I
may my husband and I have you're quite a
bit over your time Sor I will wrap it up
thank you great the bill should also
include
transponders it has to have a point
where we can add transponders to the
sprays mechanism on these planes if you
come into New Hampshire put a
transponder on your sprayer and then we
will have transponders on the ground and
we will automatically shut off those
sprayers when you enter New Hampshire
ground or air that is what needs to
happen forget the $500,000 fine and a
felony because people who are doing this
have the money to pay it we need to put
transponders on the ground and in the
air and we do have some ideas if you're
if you don't know how to do
this reach out to me because we'll
figure it
out and I'm done okay great thank you
very much all right next up is Tina flag
of
stratum hi thank you my name is Tina
flag stratum New Hampshire and I don't
have anything prepared because I
basically just found out about this also
within the week
it's um pretty much flying under the
radar no pun intended um I've heard a
the since I've been here people
testifying facts very you know poignant
facts and things about the Constitution
and our rights and pollution and it's
it's all
true I don't I really don't understand I
just want to offer some common sense and
um acknowledgment of what I see I don't
know why we're the ones having to tell
you guys about what's going on in the
sky when you can walk out the building
right now and look up and see it the
whole way here from the Sea Coast I was
watching whatever they are planes drones
whatever
spraying I know we're not allowed to ask
questions but if I could I would say
what are they spraying like that's it's
pretty Common Sense I've heard online
there's all kinds of you just have to to
look they're calling them stratospheric
U instead of chemtrails because you know
you can't say that it's a conspiracy
theory um and it's not contrails because
I think in in fifth grade we all learned
that condensation
evaporates these are lines that go on
for half a mile and then become walls of
clouds we're being Whited out every day
there the weather modification and it's
well documented Harvard started this
Harvard has the studies the um there's
Tes
from not Eisenhower I'm going to get
that wrong but anyway um VP from Kennedy
in the 60s uh he did a an commencement
speech and he was talking about weather
modification and he who controls the
weather will control the world I mean
they've who yeah Johnson thank you uh
Kennedy was shot on the day I was born I
should know that but anyway um so it
it's happening it's up there all you
have to do is look up just look up and
look up again and compare the sky from
now for the first time you look up to an
hour later to two hours later walk out
at dusk at night when there's a full
moon you can see massive amounts of
spraying what's in them they're being
tested they've been tested there's
definitely aluminum particulates and
I've heard Bill Gates you just type in
on a internet search Bill Gates dimming
the Sun the dimming is the documentary
everyone should see but regardless I
think we're all experiencing it and able
to see it for ourselves Bill Gates is on
video all over saying that oh I'm
thinking about investing in this program
and this is connected with Harvard
studies and P published and well
documented and he said that their goal
is climate change which we all know is a
political agenda I'm not saying we don't
pollute the the planet obviously we do
and have been but but global warming
climate chain change is a political
agenda and he was which he backs and he
says that there's the whole thing about
the sun is there because of the climate
change connection is that they want to
spray the things the particulates to
reflect the sun back to the to space in
order to block it from us be under the
guise of global warming climate change
which is crazy because we all know what
the sun gives us vitamin D almost the
only source of vitamin D we can really
get without supplementing and it is
required for every function of our
planet the food we eat and it's what's
happening is everything's being
contaminated not just mine and all the
people sitting here but all your
properties our
wells sep I mean the well the ground
water everything is being affected by
this we're all being affected everything
you drink and eat and when you walk
outside the air were being attacked on
all levels and I don't know what we were
supposed to address as far as what's in
that bill but again it's I think you
know it will probably not pass and it's
fine because it's the beginning and I
want to tell you online on the just what
I looked at myself in the last few days
people um from States all over the
country are talking about this bill even
though two local citizens started it
everyone's talking about it and saying
go New Hampshire live for your die yeah
it'll probably fail a lot of people
don't have any faith that it's going to
which is fine but people from all states
all over the country and countries all
over the world are talking about this
bill because what's happening in the sky
outside of this building is happening
all over this
planet thank
you okay thank you very much the last
pink card I have was submitted by
left I think she wanted to just take two
minutes to explain some material that
she handed out to members of the
committee while we're waiting for her I
know representative PL oh there she is
all right hang on Tom we'll get back to
you representative uh Penza you have a
couple of minutes to explain what you
handed out
earlier
so first off I'd just like to tell you
that I had
sent the committee um uh about 30 hours
worth of work and it came from the first
meeting and there were a lot of
questions I know uh chairman you
basically said that you know how does
the speak to the bill to speak to the
bill well my testimony um was in
response to all of the questions that
you guys had you know is this really
happening this type you know there was a
lot of that and so um I just want you to
please look at the email it's got about
12 attachments it has a 12-page document
in there um and it's it's really
important and of course so many people
had testimony that was relating to this
which is the White House document I have
other ones if if you need be um I am
going to amend this bill and and and do
a a straight repeal of 12f there are
multiple issues with the current bill I
understand I understand where you've
come I've heard it from everyone I've
gotten multiple calls from members of
the committee um in regards with
enforcement and other things that are
very difficult I think that um I think
we do a straight repeal in a ban and
then
um and then if there's possible to have
a study committee that would be great I
also wanted to say that the bill
probably shouldn't have been in your
committee it should have been in mine in
environment and agriculture that's where
12f the law originated from so um and
this is really it's it's it goes hand
inand we're talking about pollution in
the environment and then there's the
technology piece where you guys are at
so um you know I spoke to the speaker
about this as well and he stood but you
know knowing technicalities and stuff
like that it was already here so uh I
just wanted everybody to know that I'm
going to be doing that in regards with
an amendment um and then the other
handout that I just gave was pretty much
just showed you and I'm going to send
you this in color because it's it's just
really some of the pictures that you've
got are going to really look exactly
like this and this is right from um
scientific America or I think it is
that's what it's called and um from the
the UN a picture of exactly what we see
here in New Hampshire so um I think
that's pretty much
it thank you do you
know from your work on uh environment
and egg and or research you've done
through OS why did RSA 12f get passed in
the first
place okay
so so when so 12f came in in 1985 and
and I can give you legislation from
other states in regards with saying okay
you know we can we can modify the
weather and really without any consent
so I don't I don't have the history of
that but I can tell you the history that
it actually took place with a whole
bunch of States at the same time in
regards with I think there's 19 states
that have a weather modification bill in
2021 is when chairman Aaron put in that
um that Amendment it and it was great
and it passed but for
notification and everyone's saying okay
well Dees comes up and says oh we'd have
to have staff and all we wouldn't have
to have any of that so it should have
started right away where um you know if
it's the gentleman that's under
monitoring the air and stuff like that
uh he just should have been asking
several different federal agencies what
they were doing if they were doing
anything in New Hampshire that but that
has not happened so we can demand that
to happen because it is a loss so we can
ask the federal government what they
have been doing in New Hampshire which
is great but I think in the meantime
before the people consent I think we
repeal the law I I I don't think we have
to get into the weeds because I know a
lot of you are like how can we do this
and this wouldn't work and I think we
repeal it and then um if there's a study
committee that we can do and then put
some Protections in place as well and I
also wanted to say too that I have found
no information at all uh it pretty much
it's from the 1940s and 50s the cloud
seating is about in the midwest it never
came over to here in New Hampshire so if
uh it's just weird that the timing of
that doesn't go with the 1985 either and
I'm telling you I I was you know I think
I sent the document to you like one in
the morning um I'm no scientist but I
know a lot about this now so and it's
all from unbelievable Federal documents
everything that I sent you is uh there
is no there's no question it's all and I
did all the administrations so you can
see going back to Bush all the way up to
current day and this is under every
Administration this is a nonpartisan
thing and we really need to know what's
going on okay great thank you very much
all
right you have a uh rep Vice chair
Thomas has a comment yes uh just for
clarification are are you um in in
reference to your comment about the
where the bill should have been are you
aware that in general any bill that has
to do with air pollution comes to
Science and Tech and energy any bill
that has to do with water pollution
usually goes to Resource and Recreation
just as a matter of information so
that's most likely the way the bill was
written with all of the references to
the sky pollution uh that's most likely
here representative Gard you have a
question please come up to the table
yeah
I didn't want to take any time uh
representative Gart Northfield Franklin
I didn't want to take any time for
people that drove all the way here to
testify so I was going to wait till the
end I just wanted to two minutes you can
put on a timer I just wanted to address
a couple things from that White House
report then I'll leave you guys alone
make up few decisions I just think it's
I got here a little bit late so if I'm
repeating testimony I get stuck at
federal court they deal with some uh
federal court transparency issues on the
clock good let's go so page 15 of that
White House document that you've all
been sent a million times probably by
now the unintended outcomes of solar
radiation management what I'm concerned
about if it is or isn't happening that
doesn't really matter we're worried more
about what could happen and they admit
it in their own documents quote a
variety of unintended outcomes of SRM
are not well understood and there may be
others of which we are not aware the
known unknowns include potential changes
in precipitation patterns stratospheric
temperatures ozone amounts sea level
rise patterns of climate variability
ocean acidification productivity and
mixing terrestrial veget Coral Rel uh
reefs biodiversity crop production and
ecosystems that's like everything so
such as more frequent drought
precipitation events next paragraph gaps
remain in our understanding of how SRM
deployments might irreversibly alter the
earth's climate system so why are we
doing this anyway the long-term risks of
SRM deployments should be evaluated
using a risk vers risk approach since
SRM potentially prevent or amarate some
of the irreversible impacts of global
warming which we've never actually
established L but the point being is
they're admitting they're playing with
fire and we're told don't worry the
federal government has it under control
so I don't trust the federal government
and I think no one else should so I
appreciate you guys really taking a
serious look at this and I know I
brought it forward but it was just by
chance so take me out of the equation
and just look at the bill on its own
merits and we are totally open to
working with it but I do not want this
to end up in some NeverEnding study
committee that never goes anywhere we've
already seen how the 5G commission went
so um I would like to get a law that
actually stops this experimentation on
the books however we have to do it but
it has to have teeth because otherwise
we're just wasting our time so that's
all I wanted to say thank you very much
and I'll let whatever if you we're going
to address the committee okay thank you
appreciate
that representative I am not taking I
just don't want to get trapped up in a
cycle of never ending this he he doesn't
want to take a
question no all right so representative
committee thank you chairman BS um and
once again my question was I see a lot
of this document
documentation footnotes much of it is
government
documentation
um and when we come to
the uh exec before we come to that I was
wondering about a work session to at
least go over we have citizens who come
to us with they see a concern they ask
for their help and they gave us
documentations all I'm asking is can we
look at at
least the government and um
organizations like Noah documentation I
have a bunch in front of
me thank you chair okay so you may not
have seen it yet because I think it was
just posted this morning but on Tuesday
January thir 30th we are having a work
session on this and four other bills
prior to an executive
session so yes we will have a work
session on this
bill all right so with that we'll close
this public hearing on House Bill 1700
FN and we will start a public hearing on
HB
break
okay please take your seats ladies and
gentlemen time to get back to work I'm
going to open a public hearing on House
Bill 1472 FN relative to rebates of
Energy Efficiency funds for electric
vehicles and I'm going to introduce the
prime sponsor of this legislation
representative Rebecca McWilliams to
introduce it to us all yours Rebecca
thank you uh thank you very much chair
Vose it's a pleasure to be here I feel
like I'm on home turf with friends um
and uh if I haven't given my intro to
you yet um I represent South conquered
and you are in one of my districts right
now so it is a pleasure to host you
within my own home
District um so with that being said uh
this is House Bill
1472 uh the focus of this bill is very
simple The Proposal is a twoyear pilot
uh administered by the department of
energy uh looking at taking $3 million a
year of Reggie funds and applying it to
electric vehicle incentives um this has
been done in other states I'm going to
look at the Connecticut program
specifically as part of my testimony but
this is not an uncommon thing to do um
and also we'll talk a little bit about
Reggie and uh what we're currently doing
with Reggie and what we could be doing
with Reggie money um so that's that's
really the intent of the bill is to take
some dollars from Reggie and direct it
towards EV um cash in the hood incentive
purchase uh dollars all right so let's
talk a little bit about
Reggie
um based on the 2021 data um and I've
I've provided some handouts if you
really want to get in the weeds I don't
intend to get really in the weeds but
there's plenty of read reading material
here on um both the full Reggie report
which is a gray bar across the front the
investment of Reggie proceeds in 2021
published June 2023 reggie. org this is
available online you can also look at
the paper copy I've handed out um this
goes into depth about what other states
besides New Hampshire are doing with
Reggie dollars because um I'm might
posit that we're not being very creative
with what we're currently doing with our
Reggie funds um the second uh is dated
November 8 2022 it's from our own New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services uh and this is a Reggie annual
report um also based on our past Year's
data uh
2021 uh looking just at uh how we did as
a state where did we spend our money um
and what are the trends moving forward
um so this is this is sort of the basis
of my thesis but you don't actually need
to look at these citations this is good
bedtime with wine reading all right so
uh in
summary uh New Hampshire's 2021 uh
Reggie funds we had 33 million in Reggie
allowance proceeds uh from our our large
uh emitters who contributed to the
program of that 33 million um we we took
approximately 29.6 million and we use
that to provide direct bill assistance
to New Hampshire Electric
consumers so that's the Lion Share 29.6
million out of 33 million was directly
to our electric
consumers um another 50,000 was
allocated to Energy Efficiency program
focusing on moderate Inc income
households New Hampshire saves among
other programs um and then finally the
remaining auction proceeds of
approximately 200,000 covered related
Reggie administrative expenses so paying
for staff to manage these funds coming
in and out of the program so um that's
what New Hampshire has been doing with
uh Reggie funds and this proposal for
this bill is to take another $3 million
that we're not currently using that is
part of the 29.6 million being refunded
to the electric consumers and instead
directed over a 2-year period um to
purchasing uh to helping people purchase
EVS so um the precedent for this is the
Connecticut Cash on the hood program um
I have another really thick reference
this is the Conneticut chap PR annual
report I haven't passed this out to
everyone but you can look it up if you
want to get into the Weeds about
Connecticut's program I will give one
for the record it's another thick
document um so just to summarize the
Connecticut cheaper program in 2020
Connecticut adopted legislation
codifying the cheaper pilot program
which provides $3 million in funding per
year for six years um so it's been
codified into
law uh it initially consisted of three
different incentives um it's a point of
sale rebate that means the money is
offered as cash on the hood and
immediately reduces the purchase price
of the vehicle and this is important
people are much more likely to buy if
they can immediately get a discount at
the dealership rather than waiting until
they file their taxes to get some kind
of money later on in the year or the
following
year uh there are also Al participate in
Connecticut automotive dealers so they
had to opt in to be uh Sellers as part
of the cheaper program um and it the
rebate is based on elig income eligible
qualified purchasers or lessies of new
EVS um it also includes used EVS so we
do have a used market for EVS in New
Hampshire as well it's just starting up
but it's starting to become much more
popular um we're seeing that it's a
common car for teenagers if you have a
16-year-old who's only going to be a
local driver or purchasing a used EV is
becoming um the thing to do um finally
in Connecticut's program the incentives
are paid directly to the consumers who
apply um after they've done the purchase
or lease documents so they need to
submit the documents get the money
um Connecticut had a uh a goal of
achieving a certain percentage uh they
wanted to get up to I believe it was
250,000 EVS on the road by 2030 so this
program is is part of a state goal to
get there um and we're we're not
currently based on a state goal in New
Hampshire but we could talk about what
is our ideal for implementing more EVS
if we were to set a goal that's not part
of this bill but it's a distinguishment
um finally the Connecticut Cash on the
hood program is between $500 and $1,500
per electrified vehicle and that depends
on the battery range so if it has a 200
mile or greater battery range then they
get, 1500 if it's 200 or less 5 00 if
it's a plug-in hybrid also 500 so that's
both electricity and gas for the plug-in
hybrid um so that's just in a nutshell a
summary of what's happening in
Connecticut with the cheaper program all
right so uh the purpose of this bill why
are we talking about this New Hampshire
as we know we have struggled every year
in the winter with intermittent
electricity and electricity outages
right we have big storms trees go over
the lines we run out of power we're out
for a day or two or three and we're just
waiting for the lines to get repaired to
get back on the grid um I've handed out
an article from The Washington Post that
states electric vehicles can now power
your home for 3 days so instead of
having to go out and purchase a
generator every couple of years uh when
it no longer works or kicks the bucket
um you could actually use your vehicle
and the article talks about using a Ford
but I really don't want to say that's
the only vehicle you can use just the
example here is a Ford F-150 that can
use to power your home while the power
is out um so that you can still keep
things running like your refrigerator or
if you're like me your modem and your
laptop um so that you can keep yourself
in business even without the power uh
functioning and so really what this is
about is energy Independence we're
talking about the plan for the next 10
15 20 years for the State of New
Hampshire and what can we do to be
independent knowing that it's going to
take a very long time for us to have
either micro grids or up our grids but
if we're talking about combining EVS
with generators then it's a whole
different ball game right so the idea
here is to be a little bit like
Nostradamus and look into the future who
do we want to be what do we want to do
as a state how can we incentivize the
behavior so that people can be
independent and so that's really the
pieces that I wanted to put together to
introduce this bill for you and with
questions thank you representative I
have to say I love the uh cash on the
hood uh slogan for this bill it's very
very
clever so I do have a question though
sure part of our job when we write bills
as policy makers is to develop a policy
that can be implemented by the people we
ask to implement those policies so I'm
curious to know on p on lines 8
n eight and nine of the bill it says
that that the department of energy shall
develop and Implement a so-called cash
on the hood program for point of sale
electric vehicle rebates to
buyers but it doesn't give
any direction to the Department of
energy for
example what would the rebate be now you
cited that Connecticut had a range of 5
to 1500
but would the department of energy know
that um it the bill doesn't make any
reference whatso ever to what the rebate
should be nor is there any instruction
to the department about how to set up a
rebate program I mean would it go to the
dealer would it go directly to the to
the customer how would it all work um do
you think maybe that should have been
specified in the legislation uh thank
you very much for the question chair
Vose um on on both
fronts I think I would look to the
Connecticut President right the the 5 to
1500 seems to be the going rate is um
and also how how does it work in
Connecticut you need to sign the
documents and it has to last for 30 days
in order for you to get your dollars so
after 30 days in Connecticut you can't
return a vehicle to the dealer and still
have your your purchase price honored um
I'm not sure because I'm not in the
business of Automotive dealing in New
Hampshire but I understand that we do
have certain laws that we would want to
follow in terms of if someone purchases
an EV and then has buyers Morse the next
day or the next week they wouldn't be
able to get their rebate and get around
this right um th this was somewhat
intentional to allow the department of
energy latitude to do the adoption
without us putting a whole bunch of
strings attached I I was keeping it
vague on purpose but I'm also open to
doing an amendment that puts some guard
rails on there to make sure that the
department of energy is not giving one
buyer something like $10,000 right I
think that would be way outside what's
normal for this program so I'm happy to
amend it to address those two issues
thank you
so RSA 541a the administrative
procedures law basically says that
agencies can't develop
rules unless there is legislation that
specifically authorizes the rules so for
them to set up a
program which would have to be
administered through rules we would have
to give them
explicit instructions and legislation
about what rules they could write
wouldn't
we you know I've seen an awful lot of
things pass out of out of the house and
get signed by the governor that I don't
consider to be particularly explicit
I've done a lot of work in child care in
the last six years and much of it has
been just guidelines and then the rules
that were promulgated were were sort of
a negotiation after the legislation was
signed um so I'm not saying that we want
this to be like that but I have seen
some more vague language be acceptable
and I agree with you that we could be a
lot more guard railed about the way this
is set up okay the department of energy
is going to testify later so maybe
they'll have some ideas on this
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question um actually I think you asked
my question but um my concern was along
the lines of of who
decides the amount for each situation
and I'm hearing you say that it should
be based on on the Connecticut
guidelines is that is that correct
so there are other seats doing it
besides Connecticut but it seems like
Connecticut was fairly reasonable um we
could certainly do a deep dive into
other states that have also done this
and and the amounts vary sometimes at
it's 800 sometimes it's 1,750 you know
the the numbers range but there there's
a pretty good sense of where we're at in
terms of the batter's capacity whether
it's 200 or less or 200 or more in terms
of a cut off for where the larger amount
is
applied
thank you representative McGee has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question um looking at
the language of the bill again um it it
gives the department of energy uh the
requirement of developing and
implementing a cash on the hood program
but it does explicitly say point of sale
right so it kind of indicates that that
the dealers Car Sales folks will be
involved in the in the in the program
right they will just secure the funding
from doe is
that so when they make a sale they're
going to get a cash rebate they have to
go to the Department of energy to get
that rebate I think that's the intention
is that at the time the purchase is made
with certain clawback Provisions right
if someone Returns the car the deal is
dead but at the time that the purchase
is made we want people to be able to
have those funds applied to the purchase
so yes point of sale would mean that the
dealership is involved in that that the
funds are being directed to purchase the
car point of sale rather than you get a
check and you can end up buying a new
fridge with it after you've already
spent your own funds on a
car so to clarify then that what that
interaction looks like then to me is you
go to buy the car the rebate exists the
dealer applies the rebate lowers the
cost of what you're buying and then gets
reimbursement from the
yes representative Corman had a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative MC Williams for taking my
question um so in a sense this
represents uh shifting some some money
from rate payers to people buying EVS
what would be the effect on on a typical
rate
payer
so to be clear what we're doing with
Reggie 33 million a year is TW taking
29.5 of that and giving it back to rate
payers um to help it's about 21 cents a
month per household if you take the
average electric cost so we're helping
to defay their funds by 21 cents a month
um that's with the
29.5 uh million being returned if we
reduce that to
20 6.5 right I'm doing the math in my
head 26.5 million instead of
29.5 then um I'm I'm not going to do all
the math out loud here with you but that
would be the math is instead of 21 cents
month representative bernardy has a
question thanks Mr chairman so uh since
it's I think fairly well documented that
most EV purchasers are weal ithier
individuals you want to give a uh rebate
to wealthier individuals and detract
even if it's a minor amount from rate
payers their their rebates H how do you
square that
Equity thank you for the question
representative Bernardi I would say that
um when we're talking about things that
are technology on the bleeding edge
often the people who are adopting are
the wealthy because they can afford Bo
to make mistakes on the bleeding edge I
would pause it to you that we are past
the bleeding edge right now and now
we're getting closer to Cutting Edge uh
where more and more people are entering
the market not just the wealthy I know
we see at the the tip when someone can
afford to take a very large risk and
lose that kind of money the adopters
tend to be the far wealthier folks we're
no longer there with EVS it's becoming
much more mainstream um the example that
I gave earlier when you have a
16-year-old and it's their first car
this is not really a wealthy person kind
of thing to get a used for your
16-year-old this is pretty typical
you're looking for a somewhat junky car
that your 16-year-old might get into an
accident with uh but you want to make
sure that you're buying something that's
safe for your 16-year-old and also it's
probably going to be fairly inexpensive
still still could get a rebate because
that's the whole point of the program
also um as I mentioned the Connecticut
program is subject to in income
guidelines and though it doesn't say it
in the bill if we are going to amend
this to add some guard I think it makes
sense to add income guidelines um so
Connecticut has um for an individual or
for a married couple uh tax amounts that
people can be making that are acceptable
to participate in the program or you
just make too much you're not eligible
and so I would say for this program I
think that makes sense we're not looking
to give money and take money from
everyone and give it to the wealthy
that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about an incentive to help
push the market uh which would be based
on Fair fairness for everyone
involved representative licki has a
question uh thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question uh you
mentioned the 200 mile range would that
be name plate range and if it's a used
vehicle would the range reflect for
instance a 5-year-old battery in the
winter with the Heat going and how would
we determine these things uh thank you
for the question representative lii I
would say it's name plate um and I don't
know about the the math to trct
Performance Based on five years I can't
answer
that representative rolds has a
question just uh uh thank you Mr
chairman though I just wanted to make
maybe a clarification a clarification as
as an EV owner I'm a little bit familiar
I
think if I may um representa MC Williams
you you referred to the Connecticut
program it's not the range of the
battery it's the kilowatt hour capacity
of the battery that is the defining U
metric and that's not something that
changes over time
um it's like a size of a fuel
tank um I I I'm sorry I can't speak in
that specific uh I I I just don't know
enough to answer that okay well I'm
hoping to
help okay additional questions
representative
Corman thank you again and thank you
again representative Williams so if this
would apply to used EV sales then
presumably that would would that be only
for used EV sales that go through a
dealer or if representative rolds wants
to sell me his id4 then I get cash on
the hood the intention here is with
dealerships um once again and I
apologize we haven't put a ton of
guardrails in here but the intention
here is we're trying to incentivize
purchases through dealerships so I would
say if you were to go on Craigslist and
buy a used DV you would not be able to
access these funds from Department of
energy to try to get a
discount followup and if I go to uh
bills used car lot would it apply there
if bills used car lot is a dealership in
there okay representative partiall has a
question thank you chair Vos um having
us gone to not bills used car lot but
another car lot
and being on a fixed income I was very
grateful for the federal rebate but I
think you're absolutely right cash on
the hood is a big motivator for a lot of
people that's not my question it's my
comment um my question is more of a of a
maybe an ideological one
um having written a little bit of
legislation myself at this point in my
very brief career I sometimes feel like
the enormity of a law that is obviously
is ground uh game Chang changing is this
is best left to a number of eyes and um
within a work group within a work study
group or something like that rather than
try to uh imagine every scenario as the
drafty sometimes is being asked to do
could could you and would you imagine
this going to a uh work group of somehow
guardrails um so I understand the way
that this committee has been functioning
during this house session is that we do
have work session time set aside to work
as a group and hash out details on a
bill I would be happy to do that with
the members of this committee if it's
to representative Noel has a question
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question uh you had mentioned the
Connecticut program is set up for six
years where you were intending this
program to follow that also uh thank you
for the question I I put it in the text
to the bill it's a two-year pilot so
you okay seeing no other questions thank
you for introducing this proposed
legislation and now I'll call on thank
you Mr Griffin robers of the Department
perspective good afternoon Mr robers and
welcome again good
afternoon
thank you chairman Vose uh members of
the committee uh for the record sorry uh
Griffin
R back that up up a little bit um for
the record Griffin robers um New
Hampshire Department of energy here to
testify in opposition to House Bill
1472 as uh
introduced um by way of background um
and I'm sure folks on this committee are
well aware of how Reggie functions but
uh for those who don't uh the state
currently participates in What's called
the regional greenhouse gas initiative
uh to cap and reduce CO2 emissions uh
from the power sector um this initiative
creates a market for emission allowances
through a regional cap and trade program
that other states take part in um New
Hampshire allowances are sold at
quarterly auctions and the proceeds fund
the state's Energy Efficiency fund uh
this is a state dedicated fund uh
created under State Statute to receive
all of the allowance proceeds from uh
Reggie under State Statute um all
amounts in excess of the first dollar uh
for every allowance are rebated back to
retail Electric customers based on a per
kilowatt hour basis all remaining
proceeds are allocated out as you'll see
in my letter of testimony and all of
that is required under State
Statute this bill as introduced proposes
to carve out $3 million from Reggie
proceeds that are rebated back to re uh
electric retail customers the department
is then tasked with developing and
implementing a cash on the hood program
for point of sale EV rebates to buyers
and the program shall be a 2-year pilot
program
um for a variety of reasons the
department is opposed to this bill um
the first uh is that it would result in
a loss of a $3 million um rebate amount
to Electric rate payers again as I
mentioned under current law all amounts
in excess of that $1 um threshold are
rebate back to Electric customers the
loss of $3 million in rebates would
would lead to a $3 million increase in
electricity cost to Electric customers
and this would come at a time when New
Hampshire's electric rate rates are
decreasing given the massive price
spikes that we saw during 2022 to
2023 uh secondly uh as noted in the
fiscal note um the bill does not
authorize any new positions nor does it
provide any funding to cover any
estimated internal expenditures needed
by the department to implement this
program um the department does not
currently have the administrative
resources to oversee this this rebate
program especially a point of sale
rebate program that requires a lot of
moving parts for rebates to be available
at the point of
sale additionally there is a lack of
clarity on the program's start and
sunset um I do understand based on uh
the previous testimony as well as the
bill that the Bill calls for an initial
two-year pilot rebate program but uh
there is no fixed Program start date
assuming the program you know began July
1 of this year the department would not
be in any position to start that rebate
program without adequate administr
resources there is also no Sunset to the
funding mechanism while the bill
indicates the program runs for two years
time the funding keeps coming to US
every year um so following that two-year
period under this bill the department
would be appropriate 3 million after
that two-year period every year to
implement a program that we have no
authority to implement any longer um as
has been mentioned the department also
has uh concerns with the lack of any
direction on program design such
examples were mentioned earlier in
previous testimony but it would also
include what the amount is re uh the
amount the rebate is set for whether
it's means tested who is eligible should
there be a differentiation between new
and used EVS um one could potentially be
giving a rebate to somebody a
Massachusetts resident who comes up here
to New Hampshire to buy an EV car the
bill does not give the department any
authority to enforce any program design
decisions without clear legislative
Authority for example the department
could offer a $55,000 rebate to a
consumer and in theory the department
could receive a legal Challenge from
somebody wanting a larger rebate amount
without any statutory or administrative
rule as a legal basis any and every
program design could be challenged by
anybody and then finally I did want to
note that there are existing Federal
incentives uh through the inflation
reduction act for the purchase of EVS um
there is up to a uh $7,500 federal tax
credit
uh available to buyers for a new uh
qualifying EV and another tax credit of
up to 4,500 for existing or pre-owned
EVS um given the uh number of concerns
the department has with this bill um we
did want to note that there are several
ongoing or proposed study committees
looking at EV deployment here in the
state um this committee might want to
consider bringing this bill forward in
those forms to discuss it um examples
include the new New Hampshire
Transportation Council which has been
around for a number of years um last
year there was the committee to study
funding mechanisms for EV charging
infrastructure that bill was signed into
law in August and as far as I checked
this morning the committee has not met
yet and then finally I believe that
there's somebody in this room who has a
bill that would propose a study a study
commission looking at barriers um on EV
use and sales um that bill is pending in
another Committee in the house Public
Works and highways committee and that
might be another form to maybe discuss
uh changes like this um with that I'll
close my testimony and thank you very
much thank you so it sounds like you're
pointing out that this bill offers no
sunset sunset for the uh $3 million
Appropriations just wiped out the
department of Energy's annual Aruba
vacation
fund um I didn't hear a question in
there I heard a statement
so um but there was no question but just
I guess to respond to that at least a
little bit is that yes as I uh mentioned
in uh number three in our letter of
testimony is that the bill does indicate
that the program would run as a pilot
for two years however there's no repeal
of that provision after two years no
explicit Sunset so while we have the
statutory authority to implement this
this program that 2 million every year
will continue coming to after the 2-year
window has closed because again that
that language is not being removed in
any way shape or
form questions for Mr Roberge
representative muns has one thank you Mr
chair Mr Roberge welcome back um so I
understand that the the Reggie money
would kind of that Doe has oversight for
that but is doe the right Department to
administer something like this should it
should it be like the Department of
Revenue Administration I mean you know
they they deal with handing out money
regularly I I'm I'm just asking sure
thank you for the question you
know I guess I would say and I'm trying
to be careful because there is somebody
behind me from another state agency but
um you know when it comes to State EV
policy typically the two lead agencies
tend to be the New Hampshire Department
of Transportation and the Department of
Environmental servic here in the state
um the department of
energy doesn't drive EV policy in the
state no pun intended but um that might
be something that this this committee
might want to consider but if this bill
as the bill is drafted right now it
would be housed with us we are obviously
outlining concerns with the current
language as it's written followup
followup um no I I I don't disagree that
from a policy point of view the doe and
your counterparts sitting in the back is
probably the the right agencies I'm I
guess I'm thinking more about the me the
the the administration of the the
mechanics
of allocating money state money or
sending State money to car dealerships
um you know reviewing those applications
I
mean that to me it doesn't sound like
that's something that's part of Doe's
infrastructure whereas somebody like the
Department of Revenue Administration
they might have the Manpower already to
handle that and it wouldn't be a major
burden for them yeah sure uh I guess I
would say potentially you'd have to ask
the Dr about their infrastructure
respectfully thank
you representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Rober thank you um you know you in your
in your testimony you say you're opposed
to the bill for Technical and policy
reasons and you know I can understand
some of the technical reasons or
somewhat I can understand the technical
reasons maybe the the Staffing is an
issue and although I always feel that
you know that if Staffing is an issue
you can you go out and hire somebody and
and and that should be in the fiscal
note but um but I need some
clarification from you on the policy
issues and I'm assuming that the policy
uh opposition is in the in the in the in
the question of the rebate going back or
being not going back to the to the rate
payers so and and in your testimony you
say this comes at a time when when rates
are actually decreasing so what is the
the can you be more clear about what the
policy opposition are you just simply
opposed to any change in the uh
structure of the Reggie no and thank you
for the question so I guess our policy
concern was that new electric rates have
been high due to the Ukrainian crisis
inflationary price spikes in recent
years and now rate payers are starting
to see some relief as rates are starting
to stabilize and decrease we have
concern with passing a $3 million
increase to Electric rate payers at this
this time given that rate pairs have had
a very
sizable rate increase for some years
they're starting to get some relief we
don't think we should be increasing
their time at a time when rates are
starting to go
down followup okay but that that seems
like sort of a random line of thought I
mean at what point Is it feasible for
for that money to uh you know be be uh
targeted to another use as opposed to
just being returned to the raid pairs is
there is there ever a Time like would it
take a 10-year dip in prices or a
10-month dip in prices yep what is the
cut off sure then thank you for the
question so that I guess I'd kick it
back to the committee is that that is
something the legislature you know has
jurisdiction over as to whether or not
um or how these rebate do I'm sorry
these Reggie proceeds are used obviously
under State Statute everything in excess
of the $1 rebate threshold is rebate
back to customers that is what the
legislature in the past has deemed
appropriate um and a certain portion is
is allocated into existing Energy
Efficiency programs um I cannot speak
what the future will look like or any
qualifiers you know this committee makes
the determination as to how those
dollars are used we would just
respectfully feel that after a time of
significant rate increases and energy
cost spikes that we should not be moving
back in that direction if if we can
control the policy to do that we should
avoid
it representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Ro for my question it's kind of a follow
on in that same vein because it really
does come down to the money and how much
of an impact it has and um I I think um
we've gone back and forth for a while in
whether or not we should be trying to
make more impactful use of that money
rather than pennies per Bill do you have
any calculations on that because I know
in the past you've testified with what
you think the $3 million I believe it
was representative McWilliams testimony
that was about about 21 cents per month
per Bill and how many rate payers do we
have in New Hampshire so we can actually
do the math if we want to sure and thank
you for the question I households or
whatever sure um so I think
representative Mick Williams had used
2021 data uh before coming here today I
had tried to pull up some 2022 data
so it might be easier to send in an
email but um to try to keep it fairly
high level without getting too far deep
into to the math assuming a residential
uh rate payer using 650 kilowatt hours
um in
2022 they were re back
$28.98 roughly and that's again assuming
a
650 uh per year that's correct um yes
that's that's what I have here and I
would just remind the committee last
year I messed up Reggie numbers
spectacularly during one of my testimony
I that's at least what I have here today
if we're going to go deeper into the
math I'm going to say I'm going to come
back to you please and follow up
sure so the followup to that would be um
I I am not aware of anyone who who
understood when their bills shot up that
they were getting a Reggie rebate in
other words I don't think the rebate is
large enough that anybody really you
know knows and we're not talking about
removing the entire rebate right this
this program is just a small portion so
um I just wanted to qu sort of clarify
that on the record because you brought
it up as a one of the reasons for the
opposition from the doe and as you said
it's up to the legislature to determine
how the money is used and if it changes
how it changes so yeah no that's correct
okay thanks thank
you representative parshall has a
question thank you chair V and thank you
for being here today thank you um one of
the things you mentioned was a stability
and when I'm seeing this program I'm
seeing
one of the concepts that's addressed is
battery storage on a local level could
reduce our time of
day uh Reliance upon uh well basically
flatten our curve yes our you know and
and to me that's a very big thing if we
can reduce that Peak predictably we can
reduce rates and um I hopefully they
would reduce rates and so I see this as
a move towards that using Regional
greenhouse gas initiative funds for
something that really actually does
reduce greenhouse gas and also reduce
reduces rates and provides stability I
that's how I see it I I I don't mean to
make it a debate on this but could you
please uh maybe tell me where my
thinking is not accurate on this I'd be
welcome to hear it sure no uh thank you
for the question so um yes battery
storage does have the potential to I
guess put power back onto the Grid at
times when it's certainly most needed to
reduce as you mentioned those Peaks and
Val uh Peaks I guess I would say um the
other thing I would note is that um we
do uh the department has been working um
on a bill in the Senate that would
modify an ex that would a little bit
modify an existing battery storage
investigation that we have
responsibility over which I'm sure um
this committee May likely see if the
Senate passes that bill um so i' would
say we're certainly aware of of the
benefit that battery storage may have
yep so as a followup to that
question wouldn't it make sense to do a
pilot program on using EV battery
storage
to augment the grid
before doing a pilot program on taking
money to use taking money and use it for
cash on the hood
car buying pilot
program because even though that's
touted as one of the possible advantages
of more EVS we don't know if that's
actually going to work yet nobody's
tried that yet isn't that correct yes uh
thank you for the question so that is
correct and obviously it you know
whether or not this legislature wants to
require a pilot to look into
specifically EV batteries and their
benefits that's certainly something
within its purview um that is maybe one
of the reasons I had suggested the three
different forms at the tail end of my
letter is that you know there's
certainly pros and cons to this approach
probably best to discuss it with um a
more inclusive set of stakeholders in
the Forum that's been established for
some time um you know get all parties in
the room to kind of see if there's a a
path
forward additional
questions seeing none thank you Mr
robers I have no other pink
cards that uh from people who want want
to testify although Michael Fitzgerald
from the Department of New Hampshire uh
Environmental Services is here to answer
questions if anybody on the committee
has a question regarding this
legislation does anyone have
any apparently so so Mr fitzg you're
up can't let you leave the room unac
costed every time Michael and
representative McGee gets the first
question ah thank you Mr chair m
question has to do with um I know you're
embroiled in planning around the climate
action plan that needs to be submitted
by next march and I'm just wondering
whether a program like this in any way
would fold into the types of
um types of pieces of the plan that
you're looking at at this point I'm just
we don't have a lot in the works that
maybe will dovetail with the work that
you're doing so I just was wondering if
if we could know that so thank you
that's a very timely question um
unfortunately the the uh you're you're
just a hair hair ahead of the timing um
by February 1st we have to submit a
notice of intent to the federal
government on whether we plan to apply
for um cprg $4.6 billion in cprg funding
that is uh uh become that will become
available in April and we're in the
process right now of doing Outreach
sessions and collecting information from
citizens of New Hampshire from
organizations uh you know from a wide
variety of stakeholders to to inform uh
our what's known as a peap priority
climate action plan um that that is
required as of March 1st so those
decisions are coming up very shortly and
um but we have we this is certainly
consistent with a lot of the information
that we are um receiving for support of
EVS uh and transitioning to to um EV
infrastructure Etc um but um we haven't
made any ultimate decisions at this
point can I have a followup
well Mr Fitzgerald volunteered to come
here to speak to us if we had questions
about this bill M and now you're asking
questions that have nothing to do with
the bill so well can you ask a question
about the bill s yes okay um yes I I I
see them as related so that's just my
brain but um so my question is whether
or not it is helpful to have a bill like
this in order to
um point to uh as far as something going
on in the state that you're going to be
reporting as part of the plan I me
that's what I'm trying to figure out is
is there a connection
between this
bill uh I would I would say at this
point um this wouldn't necessarily have
an impact it certainly wouldn't hurt um
but it would not necessarily have an
impact on our our plans for the pcap uh
and again we have limited guidance from
the feds as to how that 4.6 billion is
going to be allocated at this point in
time uh and so um again this is
certainly somewhat consistent but um I I
I don't think it would sway any any
decisions uh in in this arena for US
Representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Fitzgerald uh this will be quick uh
currently the bill uh envisions the
department of energy as being the the
agency that houses this pilot program
would this be more appropriate in your
agency or
Department um we've had discussions uh
on this with um doe and uh uh just just
so you're familiar the way that Reggie
works is we we're the agency that
implements the Reggie auction program
and so on WE manage the program but all
the Reggie funding comes into doe it
formerly went to the Pu um and that's
because it's it's funding that comes
from Electric rate payers ultimately and
so at that time back 10 12 years ago or
more we decided um jointly that that the
two agencies would would that Doe would
manage the the money side of it we would
manage the participation and Reggie
auction and
environmental uh pieces of it and we
would work jointly the way that the
Reggie program works is that one
commissioner from an environmental
agency and one commissioner from a uh
utility regulatory agency is uh is on
the board of Reggie from each state so
that most States Implement in that way
it's a long roundabout way of answering
your question which is that um uh doe
currently runs rebate programs for
energy programs and that sort of thing
we don't have that any of that type of
uh program uh so our thought process was
If This Were to come in we're certainly
open to it but um we we think it's more
consistent with the programs that Doe
runs and I'm sure Mr Griffin is shaking
disbelief is he on camera at least any
other questions for Mr
Fitzgerald seeing none thank you for
thank you volunteering to come by this
afternoon and answering our questions so
with that we'll close the public hearing
on House Bill
FN and before I let you all go home for
the day I want to urge you to check your
email because there are notices for
Monday and Tuesday of next week we have
six public hearings on Monday and on
Tuesday we have two more in the morning
followed by work sessions and executive
sessions in the afternoon so it's going
to be two long busy days next week the
good news is that when we finish next
week we will have completed all of the
public hearings on all of the bills
assigned to us and we will only have
eight bills left or no seven bills left
to do executive
sessions on so we're making great
progress and uh you guys have worked
really really hard and I really
appreciate it and I'm looking forward to
another couple of productive days next
Monday and Tuesday so have a good week
week